two
well hello everybody it is Wednesday May
31st
the last day of May
[Applause]
it is Wednesday and uh as we turn the
page into a beautiful June month which
is my favorite month I love June so it
was in June this year
yes it was
um
today we have a fantastic show which if
you are a frequent Watcher know that
that's kind of breaking the the usual
schedule of our terrible shows but this
one is actually going to be really good
and I promise I'm not even going to talk
about
um Babylon reach that much
10 minutes
actually you know what you know what Dan
you can even do a timer really say you
have 10 minutes and I'll get it all out
that's interesting because I know a lot
of you guys
it's almost like they're blessing and
cursed that they're so dumb and boring
that it's like
because I want to talk about them but
the audience don't like watching it
because they're so dumb and boring
but yeah they made a they made a pretty
explosive video about me and then they
erased it
after a few hours it reminded me
of Logan Paul's first video uh
attacking coffee Zilla you remember that
right right yeah then he looks stupid
then he erased him put out a like a more
tame one that's what they did
um
they did a uh Ethan is racist that was
their response actually so I I guess I
haven't officially started talking about
them you can't start the timer yet I
started at 45 seconds ago no no no no no
no no no no this isn't it
right now oh yeah they may so so they
right
so they um in the video basically
instead of reacting responding to any
point I made they just said Ethan's uh
racist
therefore his points are invalid I guess
also the stuff they cut in there is
absolutely insane
also they made fun of my Tourette's also
they did a timer they started they did
sad violin over Olivia I'm telling you
it'll be it's gonna be fun
but I'm not but I'm just setting it up
nope it's up the timer
is there a sport when you're on field
that you do the timer and then when
you're off it stops it's like that
you know what I mean
chess
thank you chess yeah oh chess it's like
it's like 1D chess
yeah but uh we've got actually
a really fantastic thank you so much
really amazing uh
segment today by our one and only Zach
who is as you guys know
somewhat of a Lego fanatic
to say the least yeah you would you
would even put it in stronger terms
a Lego psychotic I mean uh yeah
um brick mind
um Rick bricked up I'm bricked up baby
yeah so um
in an effort to I guess
become the Lego King
in essence uh he got banned from the
Lego store
But ultimately we did end up if you can
just cut to the Box
do can we do that
there is here a special surprise
this is real stuff I know like
oh this is a real boat this is a real
box oh my God
it's real
and underneath there is a Lego surprise
that is going to blow everybody's mind
it is of course a hunger ff's prolapse
Lego size coming to a Lego store near
you spoiler
but it's Wednesday we all had a good uh
Monday memorializing our fallen heroes
yeah
I took your advice
I went and did the Topgolf thing this
weekend oh you did I did tell me about
it
it was really cool isn't it
awesome I had a lot of fun it was really
fun uh yeah one with a bunch of buddies
and uh yeah the whole did you play like
the games the games make no sense to me
I don't understand them oh the games
were the best part they I don't
understand it their points seem random
we played uh we're just driving me and
my buddy I played uh Angry Birds okay
and you like knock over in virtual
reality like the
the towers with the little piggies on
them or whatever okay and uh it was a
lot of fun I guess I'll do that you
gotta do it Topgolf is like technology
gone right
that's right this is the best
application Logan yeah Topgolf forever
uh but anyone else have a fun uh time
memorializing our fallen heroes uh yeah
me CAM Lena and uh Ali we went to San
Diego uh for the day
and uh more importantly I got the master
sword and Zelda oh I did that too yeah
oh you got it see I I'm so motivated
after he sent the screenshot I've been
playing a lot you know and I'm like I
still feel like I haven't barely
scratched the surface of the game
there's just so much to do in the game
but congratulations on the Masters thank
you thank you I do have a few legendary
weapons that I've got indeed indeed and
I know there's a way to repair them I
just don't know how to do that yet
same same no spoilers chap please yeah
please
Steve the second amendment protects your
right to own nuclear weapons yeah no
nothing that extreme it's just like an
ax in a bow
yeah
but uh me Ila and the kids went down to
San Diego
uh and it was great we had a fun time
Bruce said Theodore
oh that cute that is cute yeah
uh we had a really fun time down there
just enjoying our time and spending time
with the kids
so yeah Memorial Day rules
great holiday
thank you thank you for um for dying so
that we can have the day off
I didn't say that
I did not I would say this thank you for
your service
that's Veterans Day you made the
ultimate sacrifice no this is
specifically people who died yeah they
made the ultimate sacrifice that's what
I said I said thank you for dying yeah
exactly no thank you you made the
ultimate sacrifice for my freedom
she's also done that's another way of
putting the same thing yeah thank you
for your service thank you thank you
right
disrespectful service that you
provided is dying thank you for going
door and by the way I'm not blaming them
thank you for going door to door in a
small Afghani Village
no again that's Veterans Day no but they
did because not all people that did that
die not all people that did that diet
I'm talking about the ones that did die
me too
thank you for dying that's what I'm
saying
you can't say that to our beloved Fallen
Soldiers
are you really I feel like we're on the
same page here I I don't I don't get it
I was saying they did not die in vain
our brave warriors who went door-to-door
in small Afghani Villages torching crops
and
uh
lawlessly arresting people die that's of
course a crime by art
government and Military complex there of
course
deserve to be memorialized
you know what I mean right
245 years of slinging dick baby
America
true haven't missed a day
perfect attendance
that's America
[Music]
you know speak just a little aside it's
kind of funny you know how we're having
this debt ceilings uh standoff
with the conservatives are not agreeing
to raise the debt ceiling and
threatening to put the United States in
default if they don't cut back on costs
so they force Biden to cut back on
specific costs like um
College uh forgiveness IRS funding uh oh
yeah they they made it so um you have to
work to get like social benefits now you
have to show proof of work
yet they added 40 billion dollars for uh
defense spending so
that makes a lot of sense
so congratulations to defense department
that's America
they're like people on food stamps
we need to keep an eye on them
but 40 billion
they need it they need it
it's actually quite quite uh
quite perverse
it's incredible
yeah but anyway
uh God bless the the Fallen ones
[Applause]
um
yeah it's weird uh we didn't have a show
on Monday and I feel like today's Monday
so
yeah may it is Wednesday so let's just
get right into it also just a shout out
Teddy fresh the women's Classics are out
now if you guys are interested in
picking up some
beautiful
elegant well made
exactly
and absolutely affordable
go-to classics
shop this tab and you will see this
collection that we are all so proud of
thank you guys
that's what it is
thank you
no thank you no thank you
thank you I want to give a shout out to
Jordan Peterson
always actually no I want to give a
shout out to sorry Sora this girl is
incredible she is the coolest she's made
a few animations you guys might remember
sorry sorry
um this one we must have watched this
one on the show right yeah oh it's so
good you guys are both tall you you
know what I mean it's like nobody cared
nobody's sad for you guys being not as
tall this is what I mean nobody cares
about us tall boys
that's messed up it's up being
followed some it's like some
first of all he's not that much
taller than me
just gonna say that sorry what fighting
with Ryan she has me like a dwarf in him
as like Andre Andre the Giant defending
my hype
right
why is that so mind-numbing to you
it just looks proportional man it does
not
oh how tall is D let me remind Kevin I
was a man lit what's Harvey Weinstein's
height there's lots of pictures of them
together good question
was apparently okay my ass does not
stick up so if you Google
Weinstein Ryan Kavanaugh this is a
really good experiment because there
there is a lot of images of them
standing next to each other yeah
actually you know what kind of looks
like Harvey Weinstein that's one of my
best moments in show history that's what
I've been saying bro
this is Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
weinstein.com
you know that's my website right
that's so stupid we made that website to
help the public
this is to help people like you
this is a public service did you really
not know that was our website no that's
so awesome
she's her animation is so good we
actually commissioned her to make one oh
she made a Frenemies one that was like
Mega awesome and then where's the one we
paid her to make
it's on our Channel oh we uploaded it
yeah I just sent it so let me just I
want to give her like a full shout out
because she really is so amazing
and then I'll show you every new one
because I have bad eating habits doesn't
mean you can eat licorice for breakfast
I can't wait to do dice first
I can't wait
so how was your weekend
I never know if you hate or like me like
genuinely
I genuinely don't care but but that's
one thing I'm indifferent to you like I
don't think about you outside of this
like I think it's cool because like oh
you have your own thing going and I have
something going so it's cool we do like
this collab but I don't think about you
outside of this ever
hahaha
I just indifferent
I'm guarded
and then the one that we paid her to
make uh is this one which was so I mean
this one's a masterpiece
for some reason we uploaded it didn't
get that many views or I mean compared
I'm assuming it's just because it's
short and our sort of like four hours
usually and YouTube's like nah we're not
gonna recommend this it's only four
minutes
oh yeah maybe we should put it on the
highlights but the the foot War it's
here on our Channel
this one is just wow
[Music]
I don't know I feel like there's just a
little bit too much Mutiny around here
sometimes
well
so your concern is that one of us pass
you or are you concerned is somebody not
part of the crew passing it's all
dangerous do you understand that when
United you we stand divided we fall is
my point if we're gonna rage this foot
War we can't be spreading our light
allegiances all over the place there's
one foot commander and you guys been on
this course the scoreboard compromises
all of our hard work
we cannot compromise the security of
this war okay so you're gonna lose we
all lose okay first of all this is a
this is a fluid situation okay because
when that happened all I said is that it
would be funny if Abe passed you because
a b was like freaking out about like
Ethan's gonna be mad at me if I pass him
I'm like well that would be funny then
who do you guys think you are
I'm the foot God you don't pass me
this is my foot throne
a b a thought on me I think that's
Denzel Washington scene from training
day he ain't got on me
4100 five-star ratings you forget
yourself
I ask you all today now to pledge
allegiance to me as your one true leader
of foot Nation Army
this is really how wars happened we had
this common
Cloud do you want to have your own foot
Nation you weren't as happy being under
and being under myself I was happy
nobody I didn't put myself
you're like Joffrey no I'm not insane
with power you're out of control start
listen to this a b said oh I'm doing to
protect you now all of a sudden when I'm
like yo I don't like what's happening
here you're talking about oh I'm ready
to go Mutiny and make my own nation and
then what do I gotta do I gotta go war
with you and I gotta go war with you and
then all of a sudden this nation we had
unified strong the top in the world is
now weak with war and attrition and
infighting
this is equivalent to Julius Caesar
finding out there's been betrayed yes
and it's the main perpetrator
no Julius you are Julius you're Judith
and I am Jesus okay we're we're mixing
up our metaphors here a little bit now
the point is I'm the foot Savior and you
all have without me
Ian who do you pledge allegiance to
[Music]
[Laughter]
we love uh love and Zach my golden boy
he's holding boys yeah
Ian look like running Forrest Gump love
who do you support you of course thank
you you're all fire love is executive
producer
40.
promoted I've never wanted this Mutiny
to happen yeah
Zach you're in love you're in Ian you're
in the school what did they call
that when you they put his prisoners in
um
I'm just saying this feels like how
democracy yo get that out of here I am
the Senate
yeah you're going to the gulag bro
get that out of here
your head is going on a bike
isn't she not amazing she's amazing
incredible I Love Her Style she gets the
way you move like super well the way
that you like bounce up and down when
you're talking she gets me like nobody
else yeah
and she did this all by herself
so I think she has a bright future in
animation but yes sorry sorry Sora so
here's our new one anyway I just wanted
to Cloud her up
um man I missed the foot Wiki feed days
yeah that was one of the best that whole
kingdom is crumbled now hasn't it it's
all you're like Ozymandias after that
episode
I emailed them I don't take my feet off
the website
yeah and you guys know that all the
and shenanigans is probably
what pushed them over the edge and
canceled the whole damn thing well I
couldn't I couldn't win
either way Dan was trying to set me up
yeah it's Dan's fault like usual
[Music]
I can't stand that thank you
all right so here's her new one about
Jordan Peterson
The Gamers of cups
it just meant it's Jordan Peterson
crying about how how about poor men
where will we be
ready
I know I just noticed that I'm no longer
a fan
gaming Flocka eyes
where will we be
the man what the hell are we gonna do
men
I've just I don't want without him
what would Society be
impossible things
damn it it's okay to be a man and to
build and to make rocks at the big
swimming pools working
what are we gonna do without men in the
sewers
they work themselves to death
this is a man fighting for men
[Music]
she loves showing my crack
she is the greatest I am I think she is
so amazing
but she is just incredible and she was a
pleasure to work with too so sorry Sora
we should let's put our Link in
description just doing that she's so
cool sorry
I'm sorry I'll watch those anytime
they're just they're such a treat you
know yep
here I just pinned it in the chat and
I'm put in the description by the way
sorry you're gonna have to start
um drawing me skinnier because I weighed
in at 208 today
oh
208 208 man you scared
I'm not scared at all you're a little
skinny man this has always been a carrot
it's always been a carrot
you know you know what carrots go good
in mayonnaise with like a man like a
they call like a potato salad Dan should
Mayo up that Dome is that good yeah
they're actually it is there's gonna
there's an Israeli dish they call it
mayonnaise which admittedly is a
horrible horrible name but just call it
man it's just mayonnaise okay but it's
carrots
potato egg and pickle and it is like so
much better than it sounds like and has
any right to be so good
yeah so I'm gonna put that on your head
too
no no we didn't agree to that okay we'll
see we agree to that yeah
um and should Mayo up that Dome
uh ELO's been popping off on social
media she actually put up a bang or Tick
Tock of a b
um
so I heard on the street so Amy goes and
rescue this girl who's trapped in the
bathroom she's she's pregnant I think we
should point that out too yeah
technically it was a baby there's a baby
she saved a baby everyone so you saved
the baby well what I what I heard
through the grapevine is that you guys
uh
there may have been an exchange of money
and some planning that happened behind
the scene
yeah I heard this too well the rumor you
heard was that there was it was planned
with her because yes I just heard that
AB may have just shoved her in there and
locked I I heard she was in she was on
the cut she was on the land she was in
on it she was she got her big question
she got a baby on the way you know
fine Fair maybe you guys to be the judge
AB won't fess up there is somebody at
the difference who got stuck at the
bathroom Edie are you away from the door
okay I'm gonna try to take it in
myself
give us everything you wanted
does that hurt
no maybe it slammed it pretty hard
what I believe is happening is she's
back there with some kind of chair or
something and then you'll notice right
when AB gets it open he goes okay now I
got it barely pushes the door and it
opens oh that was my my signal to back
up you'll see it right here in the vid
interesting it's right it all is here
it's your tell two three
one two three yeah well it's so hard
right so solid okay I felt so bad but
that was one of the funniest things I've
ever seen she just launched herself at
the door she looks ferocious little did
she know that it was fortified from the
inside
right
yeah oh Ela left a comment s
at this point
Ela says oh my God the animation is the
best thing ever thank you Queen
[Applause]
I'd rather just up the door okay
try it again
you're ready here goes
okay now I want you guys to watch this
frame by frame and please just watch
carefully
Listen Hold on at this point he can get
it sure now step away I don't want you
to see what's about to happen I'd rather
just up the door okay try it again
perfect she's all the way around the
corner she can't see okay oh still not
opening now watch this
you're ready here it goes here it goes
he goes now I've got it all of a sudden
it's convenient the camera for a moment
yo he didn't even go back that much he
didn't even throw like a really hard
shoulder in that moment you can see it
was like not as hard as that one
you guys see what I'm seeing look how
fast this one is
wow that really just it's like it wasn't
even blocked at all yeah AB why are you
lying
let it play Let It play okay let's see
oh my God
that's what I do you see this to anybody
that wants to box a b that's not a wedge
door thing twice that's right it doesn't
look that hard it's just like cardboard
it's like a thin-ass door
that's
I've ever seen adorable insanely hard to
get open no way it's like particle board
it's made of particles there's another
bathroom there if you guys want to try
it
you want to break another door I'm yeah
I'm not in the business of breaking my
own really since when there
when did that change I'll try it
actually I would try it
should we see who if we can break the
door
sounds pretty interesting frankly
well the question is do we have the same
door in our bathrooms as they have no
no he was very easy
I spent a lot of time looking at the
doors lately huh yeah I'm telling you
that was his thick ass door okay we can
see it it's not that thick Olivia do
some off
um
Sweden dude
Sweden you're saying that's thick
no sorry you don't know I'm saying it's
none of that thing yeah it's not that
thick Olivia do me do some Ops all right
go check the thickness of our doors go
over to Teddy fresh and check the
thickness of this one you got to use the
automotive
scale photo with my thumb oh if it's the
same size you want me to break the same
thickness
are you making measure no no just just
give me your assessment just feel it
knock tell me if it's the same density
Dan's off to get something yeah dancing
hold on hold on but wait what does that
prove
you obviously installed a weaker door
and you're not confident anymore okay
yeah that we can break the one in the
office
which I think I can do
[Music]
anything yeah yeah I'm impressed you did
good thanks
[Music]
so and then why was AV even there it
makes me wonder like why is Abe over at
Teddy fresh just coincidentally
okay at the time she's locked in so
there was a package okay my camera's
frozen there was a package
how convenient
they're trying to silence me follow
there was a package uh for Teddy fresh
here that I walked over when I walked
over Ila was there Ila said somebody was
locked in the bathroom and I said oh I
could I could probably get in there I
could get in I've gone into uh I've gone
into some doors before and she said I
felt like you'd say that I don't know
what she meant by that but uh yeah wait
Ila just made a comment she said if
we're gonna replace one we could just
replace two just saying
she's right because yes Specialists will
come I mean whoever's in uh repairing it
he could just do it twice so we should
let's run that experiment all right well
Olivia's currently running next sort of
check the density
of those doors and to compare it to ours
so and then it's rumored that AB
actually saved a orphanage
from a blaze array a raging Inferno on
the way home an orphanage 20 of them
haha
thank you guys though that good good
work baby thank you thank you and elude
I asked ELO first I'm like do you want
me to break it she's like go for it I'm
not I'm not worried about the property
you know what I mean I just want to come
out of my paycheck yeah I think that's
illegal anyway
at least in California
yeah people were saying how come we
didn't just try taking the the handle
off first we did but we couldn't get it
off and she was pregnant and
people are saying we should just get in
there so what what's the relevance of
her being pregnant she can't be under
too much stress I'm right she's locked
in the bathroom behind a hero and I was
there yeah yeah Amanda says I'm a
personal weight loss I'm in a weight
loss competition with Ethan oh we are
that's news to me last episode we were
the same way and now he's lost more it's
on you have helped me back into my
weight loss journey I initially lost 30
50 pounds oh you're way ahead of me then
girl
that's awesome good for you I love that
get inspired Amanda I'm inspiring people
Sebastian
of course we we joke uh a b he is
he's the man
he's winning
yeah um so something happened recently
with AI
and there's been a lot of people scared
about the prospects of A.I
soon to be taking their jobs
and it's not just the blue collar
workers we're looking at white collar
workers office jobs programmers but now
podcasters
this is terrifying because this
threatens all of our livelihood
uh somebody posted this by all you mean
everyone
say what by all you mean everyone in
this room yeah right this is essential
existential crisis to us
this AI is this the future of podcasting
ask this guy AI conversation with Bill
Gates and Socrates
wow I think
we could never
we could never get guessed of that
caliber no
uh I think very realistic conversation
like this will be bread and butter in
any streaming app yeah we're having
actually Adolf Hitler will be on our
show next week
have so many questions for him
uh less I'm a little worried considering
the recent Revelations about uh oh
I'm frozen you just have to listen to me
over this Frozen shot uh
given the recent Revelations of Bill
Gates predilections with Jeffrey Epstein
I'm a little worried what him and
Socrates might have in common yeah
let's take it one step further imagine
this but personalized towards you
okay guys take a look this is scary
Bill Gates my dear friend bill I see you
have brought a device with you today
what purpose does it serve green why
does he sound like that
Socrates was Greek right
so why does he sound like that sounds
like an idiot
see you have brought a device I see you
have brought the device
what the
today what purpose does it serve
greetings Socrates yeah this is a laptop
a Marvel of modern technology it Harbors
an artificial intelligence to hold the
phone so you brought these two
minds together you've you have violated
the rules of time and physics for
Socrates to come ask Bill Gates what's a
laptop
come on
that can revolutionize heuristic
education interesting imagine a world
where students learn nice natural pause
there
your own pace Guided by a tireless tutor
that Nevers is this the MacBook you
offer
Earth is that heirs
Earth no no this is a Surface you just
need to remember that surface
fascinating but tell me what is the
essence of this artificial intelligence
you speak of it is a machine that can
learn and reason so so what is inter
Socrates is just playing like a dude
that doesn't know anything about
anything why is that interesting they're
like you can feel like an idiot and not
know anything but your Socrates it's
essentially just the windows commercial
he really said dude you're getting a
Dell
yeah Socrates is playing the role of the
caveman that is baffled by the modern
world it doesn't need to be Socrates I
thought they were going to talk about
philosophy or some kind of interesting
physics or something but no he's like
what is a laptop
really interesting why am I alive what's
happening all right so Olivia's back let
me finish this and then we'll report it
yeah sure but AI can be designed to
strike a balance it need not provide
immediate answers but rather act as a
mentor gently nudging students in the
right direction while allowing them to
discover Solutions on their own he's I
fast forward he's still explaining AI to
uh Socrates at the same time AI handles
the mundane tasks giving teachers more
time to engage with students on a deeper
level but is it not through wrestling
with these mundane tasks that the soul
is strengthened and wisdom forged can a
tree grow strong if it is not buffeted
by The Winds of adversity right
technology can be a tool but does it not
also serve as a crutch right I fear that
Reliance on AI will cause humans to
become complacent right and thus cease
to engage in the very heuristic thinking
you claim it enhances right a ship's
Captain for instance must learn to
navigate the Seas on his own for he
cannot rely solely on his Compass right
just like a Windows user has to learn
how to fix this man knows what Windows
is just like Windows PM is Windows TM
the blue screen issue on their own
screen issue you lost me Socrates
just like how Microsoft stock price
continues to go up when other tech
companies stock is going down it seems
like a great time to invest in Microsoft
stock don't you think Bill Gates and on
the next episode of Bill and sock Bill
describes poop water villain suck
that's awesome
yeah so uh I'm not super scared yet yet
but who knows what
who knows I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I
can't do that all right so Ela says
there's only 150 to replace the door
that's fine so Olivia tell us your
findings yes sent the photos in WhatsApp
it's hard for me to open them directly
from Discord if you can just maybe put
them in an image or album for me love
but give me your summary did it feel to
be the same density
in terms of size I think that
it looks a little close
in terms of density and like me Swinging
the door open Petty fresh was a little
heavier okay it's a little heavier yeah
and you accept the one he broke I have a
photo of the one
um
here ours the one that he broke and then
the one next to it that didn't break and
so you're saying the one a b broke is
more dense yeah than the one we have
here
the first one so here you can see thank
you Queen you're welcome Queen
well hold on Amy this is not an
absolutely absolving it's just raises
more questions well even if they are
it's just in general it's a fake ass
door that is a thick door
that's what she said which one is this
is this ours which
all right let me go see how many hits it
takes to bash in our door let's do it
we're not yes we are Dan we're not ready
to oh
he's ready
you we're Wireless right yeah we're
ready Dan
should I lock myself in the bathroom
yeah you should I should be the princess
you should be in there and be like
you're pregnant somebody helped but the
problem before it wasn't that the
deadbolt was closed that's going to
change thing was the deadbolt stuck
close is that was preventing the door
from it no the deadbolt wasn't working
I'm not sure exactly oh wait go to the
broken one well this is a new game then
yet the deadbolt wasn't fully out wait
it looks like it was because look this
is that's where it broke oh yeah it was
it was out but the the latch wasn't
turning it like the yeah this is we we
don't have all of those experimental
conditions was the deadbolt out all the
way Olivia
[Music]
um you want me to go back yes please
okay this is important thank you
in the meantime get ready because I'm
gonna Bash one of our doors open that
means we'll only have one bathroom well
yeah well no you could still use it just
you know I mean just
knock before you go in
yeah
come on now we'll get it fixed
yeah this is off the rails after all Dan
did you not know what the episode we're
doing yeah no I I hear you I just want
to see people break stuff I don't care
bill and sock I love that uh Socrates
bill will you tell me about your
adventures with Jeffrey Epstein I have a
little bit of uh Unearthed uh extra
audio from that podcast what do you
think it's kind of quiet let me uh let
me boost boost the out of this a
second
uh tell me about the Jeffrey Epstein's
Island I had a similar Island uh Prince
what do you think about age of constant
laws in modern times you guys really had
it made back then in ovens didn't you
wow this is terrible what it's like one
of the a text to speech AI voice
generators but uh of their Bill Gates is
not very impressive apparently so uh
it's uh he was asking about age of
consent laws and uh ancient Athens oh I
I don't think they had any that's I
think anyone he said something about
having it really made I think in ancient
Greek it was a one-party consent role
as long as one person's cool with it
then right when you go below 16 like 15
and stuff like that that was that you
know by all means stop it sansi says
it's her boyfriend Richard's 21st
birthday Zach
not bad
what was that about
it's everyone's 21st everyone's 21.
just really grind your gears I didn't
know that nah it's just need some time
to breathe
sax being a little bit of a diva with
the sound bites
he's a delicate no I'm a little I'm I'm
with him on this there's no way there's
that many 21 year olds listening to this
book yeah I just don't believe it I feel
like there's got to be an element of
troll what let's do the math there's 30
let's say we get let's just say 40 000.
live viewers okay
now in every episode there's like three
people turning 21. does that seem likely
to you I think we can crunch the numbers
if you take forty thousand
okay forty thousand people and then
let's say
divided by 365.
we don't do an episode every day but no
this is I'll explain the logic okay
divide by 365. so this is the amount of
people that are having birthdays
on any given day on average so 109 109
right
and our our the average age of our
audience I would say is 20 to 30 20 to
28 you think
yeah I think it probably skews a little
bit higher but give me give me the
number you think it is I'd say like 21
to 35.
okay that's 14. so divide that by 14.
all right about 14. it's 14 pages
what's the number
7.8
so that means
that on any given day of those ages
there's seven people whose birthday it
is on for each of those numbers so it is
very possible in fact that there's three
people having 21st birthdays in fact
it's more than three by the estimation
we've just done thank you I rest my case
I think I did that math right
there should be seven people whose 21st
birthday it is per episode
on people turning 21 here just
clarify them just saying y'all calling
our audience liars I'm here I crunch the
numbers I have a beautiful mind listen
it may be true but if it is your 21st
birthday if you could include um birth
certificate photo of your ID and yeah
maybe two forms of ID actually birth
certificate would work Social Security
credit card well that's too private
birth certificate should be fine oh okay
that's fair I think that's fair if you
want the if you want the I'm 21 you
you got to reach out to one of the mods
on Discord and provide photo uh and
actually starting October uh 2025 it's
gonna need to be a real ID
um
not not one of the old style IDs so
uh so okay Olivia's back what did you
find I took a video of it can you open
that Dan yep
one moment
I think the math is right people are
saying it's wrong how is it wrong I
think it's even more per day if anything
there it is love says it's more yeah all
right here's the video
so it's not it's barely out it got stuck
it was just a nub
so I think if we're gonna the the yeah
yeah it was stuck but once we got in
there it yeah it can't open now that
it's bent here's what happened
she unlocked the deadbolt and it got
stuck part way through the closing it
looks like it was maybe a quarter out
the
vacant thing you know this is vacant she
was moving that back and forth and it
wasn't affecting the lock at all
I think it was fully out because those
things so I think the dead ball was
fully out there yeah that that makes I
don't think so
well the way the door ripped open it it
was the deadbolt that ripped it over so
let's do this I'm ready
so you're gonna slam open a door with
the deadbolt clothes with pregnant
Olivia and Olivia
all right give it
give me just one minute to get it all
set up okay okay
he's gonna take one less in there
okay and so
the uh the thesis of this experiment is
that
it's not that hard to break the door
down and this is just another layer of
ab's Deceit
does that go but it's low can can we go
back and count how many charges it took
a b
two busted down let me pull it up
let's let's see how many charges today
somebody at the refresh got stuck at the
bathroom Edie are you away from the door
okay make sure you're away from I'm
gonna try to take it in
[Music]
you guys can't see the screen
okay so that's one
[Music]
one two three oh okay and now there's
two people participating so that counts
as
we have do all the kicks you want that's
three or that counts as three because so
we got one hit and two kicks that was a
two kick here okay all right another two
Kicker
how dare you
she put her whole heart she put her
whole heart and soul into that
okay
if anything the door pushed her
why are you so hurt yourself
and then we got screwdrivers involved
okay you ready Dan
okay
well I'm gonna spread the door frame
there's a lot there's a lot of hijinks
going on think we can we can conclude
that with certainty
as we wait
um
Elon Musk is such a oh that
you know this whole thing with the
verification was to stop impersonators
and Bots
here is Elon Musk responding
to a fake Louis CK Twitter account
transposting
no jokes on this one so scroll past if
that's what you're looking for a Louis
CK gave a point by Point argument on why
uh trans people are annoying I don't
know essentially and Elon Musk out here
going
uh
sounds reasonable
that's amazing
it's his website man also I'll
be I'll be honest I saw this and I got
fooled by it for a minute like the
impersonating power is crazy on Twitter
right now there's a fake AOC account
that elon's been boosting
it's awesome
it's pretty wild I mean just considering
what he said himself about
uh what's important
so
shout out to Elon who's a giant
uh loser
all right we're ready here we go
[Music]
every day for the next
one on the left
because that's one that's usually
clogging anyways let me feel the doors
that is pretty thick actually
that's fairly thick she's having second
thoughts now did you guys hear that did
I get picked up Ethan say that it's
pretty thick yeah these are pretty Burly
and you're saying that they're
comparable
these are these are thick doors I'm not
even gonna I can't lie about it yeah
yeah now what the difference here is a b
had a lot more run run up
I'm working with not a lot of space so
if you would please lock yourself in the
bathroom at this point this one this is
the one that clogs that's why okay sure
we can do this
one right now okay and I think in my
opinion the hinge should be a quarter
you think I should only put it a quarter
that's what I think's yeah
who says I'm cheating Shredder you don't
want to be in there
come on you don't want it you don't want
any of this okay so a quarter out I
think so I think so a quarter out it's
not even gonna shut yeah yeah
I mean I feel like the experiment's a
little is that not what happened when
you know AJ was not like do it all the
way Olivia
yeah all the way
yeah it was actually even sturdier than
that believe it or not yeah sure I swear
it would not budget apparently it's Fort
Knox here
um we need another person to help me
kick because there was a double kicker
damn I mean I've got no run up here I
mean this is a Joe
I mean come on
the kicker yeah I need a double kick
okay all right so I'm gonna start by um
yeah
that's pretty heavy don't hurt yourself
yeah that is that is quite heavy here
come here Kim help me with the double
kicker yeah
that is fairly thick
[Laughter]
can I just say this is such a Michael
Scott thing right now
[Music]
two one
ready
three two one
a little bit yeah that thing is
strong bro you got this all right I'm
coming in Olivia are you okay in there
Elon I'm sorry if he gets hurt are you
okay
she's pregnant you guys all right Olivia
stay away from the door that's what I
said yesterday stay away from the door
was that a joke
yeah I just love breaking stuff
oh yeah
there's no way that deadbolt was in all
the way there's no way
there's no way
yeah go ahead now let's see after we've
loosened it up there's no way you're
getting in there okay we're good go
ahead
okay
oh
wrong with you wait Linda just walked
into this here pan over here
that was that was really well done okay
hold on hold on hold on just turn around
to eat now you now notice
okay this was the the bowl so okay
okay yeah it looks the same
all right bro why'd you break my
door
you we only have one bathroom now
[Applause]
all right well listen I'm I'm gonna
first of all me and cam damn near broke
that thing off the hinges it was all you
that was all you it was all me thank you
but I will say
I think AB saved that that before
pregnant women that's all I ever wanted
I think he did it someone to admit it I
think he did it
why are you so much
wait that's it why are you so good at
doing that it sucks bro
I I don't know I just I imagine someone
in distress and I just I get the
strength you know
it's my hero instincts can we go light a
car on fire to do MythBusters on the
other allegations
that's a good idea
all right AB did it I mean yeah thank
you I give you props
I give you props
you hit that door hard bro I I gotta
give you props man thank you thank you
that was fun I do see a lot of people
saying that also I'm wearing
Birkenstocks also I'm seeing a lot of
people say that I loosened it up really
like 90 Evie did that everyone saw that
but I give it up
that was amazing
hey B how you feeling I feel like I'm in
the office like the show that was the
most like unscripted Michael Scott thing
you've ever done yeah why are you guys
so desperate for me to be Michael Scott
it's a good thing he's beloved everyone
loves Michael Scott
yeah but come on clearly you're you know
minus the okay then who are you Dwight
I'd say I'm a mix between Dwight and uh
don't say don't you dare don't you say
Jim
the white ass
you can still be Jim but you're not
allowed to say it
yeah I was gonna say Jim because that
was yeah I know
okay all right well glad that Abe got
his the office experience so but he did
it he did
maybe he did that everybody saw it
that was exciting
it was nice to win one you know
how to know how to move on from that
it's all downhill from here
oh well I have other top of the show
stuff you guys want to do the Lego now
let's do it it
so um
let's see here Lego time all right well
Zach uh and Ian part is there anything
you guys want to say before we launch
into this Ian uh
directed this it's uh collaboration but
it is his his baby
um uh this is all Zach he's uh it was a
team effort here
people are saying AV is Ryan that's
that's interesting I didn't want to
speak up but
that's the answer so who's Jim I think
maybe yeah and
no I'm Toby oh you you're dead I'm like
I'm just a digital screen you
know what and creativity together you
know what I don't even get a camera
that's how Toby I am okay hold on
you're right I think Ian is Jim because
he's like above it all he doesn't talk
he's just like yo look at these idiots
oh that's a nice one
Dan is Jim I yeah
a b is Ryan for sure
well hold but okay I disagree the Ryan
Arc is interesting though because
Michael at first was obsessed with Ryan
he's always obsessed with him that's why
I say it doesn't make sense
maybe I'm obsessed with you that is true
I guess the early season Ryan before he
like turns evil yeah that's Ian
right he was cool at the start at the
first couple Seasons like they went
somewhere else with his character but he
was just the intern and Ian was the
original intern you know what I mean and
you always have wanted so much more from
Ian than Ian's willing to give you you
know what I mean wait dan they say
you're Oscar I love that actually I
think people have said that I'm Oscars
sometimes too
Oscar and Toby yeah I think Dan is Oscar
and tobia exactly that works and then
who is Kevin
I think we have it Kevin I wasn't gonna
say that Olivia
I'm not Kevin I'm I'm CR but mixed
between Creed and Andy oh my you you
wish you were Creed you are Andy you are
Andy you are Andy and interesting yeah
Andy that is interesting
and I proudly wear that great character
Andy uh and Annie Bernard and Andrew
Bernard what a show huh anyways the
office is this generation Seinfeld can
we say that
uh I I wouldn't even say this generation
because the show's like more than 10
years old now
yeah okay let's watch is there anything
you guys want to say uh before we launch
into this I'm Jim uh
I'm very proud of what uh we put
together want to give a shout out to um
Sam in cam
Sam for the costume design
all right this is you're not accepting
off yeah what is the setup this is I'm
just saying there's a lot of parts that
went into this that I want to you want
to thank God yeah you want to thank your
parents I don't think Jesus you want to
you want to thank your manager thank my
manager in San Diego
um all right Dan play him off all right
let's take a look okay
there we go Zach called me frantic
telling me that I have to come over
immediately it's life or death and he
insisted I bring the camera he said
you're not going to want to miss this
hot sweet action I've sprinted over here
to Zach's house so let's make sure that
he is all good
hello what the hell are you wearing bro
what are you talking about Zach what is
this Zack I'm sorry I don't Zach Zach
Lewis my name is Lego Lou thank you very
much I appreciate that I I had a
doctor's appointment okay keep your
hostility down we're at a private
residence now bring it down and come on
into my crib your crib wait it's in your
crib come on in come hit there let me
present to you the feast day Rizzo
stalls I don't know why I'm here
The Collection you said life or death
you're talking about me coming over here
and filming your LEGOs this is life or
death yeah what brand are these glasses
this is Givenchy or what are these
glasses we got here their Lego brand and
are these uh Lego uh shoes as well or
these are Jordans you want me to do like
uh MTV Cribs of your Legos is that why
I'm here yes that's exactly why you're
here and that's all you're useful for I
don't really think I no do that lower
your tone mine is fine bring it down and
welcome to my crib you said that already
lower your tone this is a house of Lego
House of God we praise Mr Gold here
who's Mr Gold see the fact that I have
to explain myself Zach I don't know I I
think I should go I probably look
put the camera down let's look at me in
the patient I'm looking you want
to be here with me would you rather be
the office working jerking or
dick off not really listen to me look at
me when you're talking
Jesus you're stressing me out with this
guy okay okay
[Music]
yes now that attitudes are adjusted look
at my uh Laker collection Darth Maul is
the newest edition shout out to Bricker
builds atat Vader Leia Dark Trooper R2D2
we got Yoda Indiana Jones we got the up
house Boba Fett Detonator Haunted
Mansion I love you so much Walt Disney
World castle everything
my sneaker collection Adidas Jordans
more Star Wars land speeder they call me
Mr Gold at home could I call your family
to verify that
turn the camera around okay
sorry 40th anniversary Return of the
Jedi more Return of the Jedi Jurassic
Park baby Yoda AKA grogu
actually I got dogs that can you help me
pick those up yeah oh all right I'll
just kind of wait Porsche 911 Turbo 73
turbo more Star Wars on Star Wars on
Star Wars we got Seinfeld on top and
then the office on below how much money
would you say to be wasted on Lego I
wouldn't call it waster I'd call it an
investment investment in my future and
in my
presence Legos are an extension of me
yeah so you're really looking at me
there's the money shot right there
how much money would you say this is I
don't like to count you don't want it
it's rude don't ever ask a man about his
financial no don't ask me in toys
watch your tongue the hand you get so
intense watch your tongue can I get you
a like a beverage or food or anything
like that uh yeah I mean I'm kind of
hungry okay cool I I've made some stuff
earlier would you like some glass of
water
what the is that I can't eat this I
made a nice spring salad do you are you
rejecting my food here I I I don't think
I can eat this I apologize where are my
manners you will you like ice with your
drink
[Music]
um look I'm very well respected in the
Lego brick Community I'm a Lego High
Roller they actually invited me to a VIP
event find it a little hard to believe
that you're like so highly respected in
the Lego organization do you not see
this custom pendant I did see that that
looks really good for you know sort of
like an Etsy deep cut let's see this big
exclusive invitation you got here come
celebrate the grand opening
then you're saying they only send that
to Lego high rollers yeah this is like
an ad this is like a Lego Instagram ad
like I think everybody got fed this ad
if they like wasted a bunch of money on
Legos no they didn't everyone knows who
I am all right I'm Lego Lou
you listen to me I'm the of a walk
you son of a when I'm rolling
there everyone bows down to me and at HQ
and at the annual meeting so don't come
in here and give me your attitude you
know what let's let's go to the LEGO
store let's please I want to see
everyone okay ballot your feet please
don't lose please you're gonna bow down
to me too I can't have you wearing that
those peasant Tire I just have like a
shirt and pants on I have an outfit for
you we're gonna get you all swagged up I
don't really want to put that no you you
have to cut a person
[Music]
all right yeah okay so yeah Ian's gonna
put on the outfit
what the is this dude I look like
bananas in pajamas is about to burgle
your house you look fantastic I'm gonna
terrify everyone at the store just just
roll it it's just like a kink thing do
you like you and Chantal wear this no
don't don't mind the stain on it I hired
an exclusive Lego VIP members only
driver we have a driver the tickets for
the Legos VIPs only let's roll
I got a driver yeah wait Sam you're here
how did you get roped into this
with this guy Zach literally made it
seem like I had to get here immediately
he had a sick nephew or something that
loves Legos well like a Make-a-Wish
thing yes it's fun part come on we're
late we gotta go I don't even think no
it's all good let's go come on are you
serious right now dude stop and cut the
camera
okay
he has this thing with the icon shut the
up if you want to go in the office
I mean what no no okay so get your act
together and let's roll all right get in
losers we're going to the LEGO store
yeah I'm on the way yeah dude I got the
driver they're rolling out the you know
brick carpet this thing is so hot hey
excuse me can I take this excuse me I'm
on the phone can you even see out of
that thing excuse me hey I literally
can't even see especially good too zip
it hey you're not even on the phone bro
they are going to throw us out I have a
VIP credit card you have a VIP Lego
credit card yes here it is but don't get
your dirty fingerprints on it
Bank of brick breakdup VIP member the
name on this says Lego Lou this is not a
valid credit card yes it is according to
who this thing is like made out of
cardboard I think these costumes are
like a kink thing does your stink yeah
mine's it's sticky but it smells like
like old Chinese food or something stop
okay sidebar do you think they'll have
the little mermaid clam shell there I've
been meaning to buy them yeah they go
they got it yeah it's in stock
[Music]
there it is
the Holy Land Act on your best behavior
I don't see the red carpet anywhere
one executive Star Destroyer please and
I'm a VIP
that's not a real card is it shut up
[Music]
okay go ahead and tap that yeah nothing
seems to be happening exactly broken you
don't know is this do you know this guy
is this guy a VIP High Roller I I don't
think I've ever seen
oh
Lego Lou with the Lego L okay well it's
like the mine
mine bears
embarrassing things you should probably
go
all right buy Lego Lou
oh he's leaving so sad did he get your
Legos shut up
shut the up you got your toys
don't touch me I'm a God I'm proving
these wrong man no one
with Lego
shut up leave me alone
you know I'm so important to that
Community they me for the
last time I'm Lego Lou God damn it I'm
gonna prove to those Danish
pieces of I am the man I'm gonna
make the ultimate most badass Kick-Ass
amazing lego set then they're gonna take
me seriously I'm gonna prove them wrong
those pieces of Lego Lou is bricked
up throw me out of the store they throw
me out of the store I'm Lego Lou I'm VIP
High Roller I'm proving them wrong no
one does that to me you're gonna do it
me you're gonna throw me out
[Music]
my masterpiece
is finished
yeah
wow yeah actually wow
when Zach left the LEGO store we
couldn't uh show what happened but Zach
had like a Lego pressure cooker with
Nails in it they left in the store who's
who's that a Lego Lou I mean he's
actually wanted by the F yeah there's a
lot of fatalities
hi hey Lego lose how you guys doing good
job guys wow what an exciting Arc and
what may I say what an impressive Lego
collection you have thank you very much
appreciate that
um can I ask you what's your favorite
Lego I love the Star Wars stuff all of
them yeah you have a single favorite one
um
I have like an atat Walker not the big
big one not the ultimate collector
series but the um
smaller scale but that's a good build
um I love the Indiana Jones ones I have
um
yeah you're a Disney boy I like the
Disney stuff too yeah all right well
Lego Lou is here to unveil his master
project and uh well though the floor is
yours Lego Lou prove them all wrong wait
a minute um do I have a drum roll on
here
I think I might
oh oh there we go ladies and gentlemen
I present to you
masterpiece
what is it
a very own H3 podcast Lego set holy
can I see a close-up of that is that
real yes it is very real
that's real it's real
it's real as rain my friend in
collaboration with Lego Allison
um we put together a beautiful One of a
Kind H3 podcast Lego set wow
let me get a close look like what the f
and you've got the crew whole crew got
all the stats you got even the Scorpion
chair how did you do that we work with
the best people in this industry right
it's the VIP access VIP access yeah
um there's so many little Easter eggs in
here
um we got Ian a-i-n Sam we got zilly
zonka we have the whole thing we have
Cam Lena uh the uh cursed Ethan head
Ethan Ela
um Olivia a b Dan in the Scorpion chair
it is one of a kind true masterpiece
unbelievable
well I have to say I am very impressed
and thank you for honoring the podcast
as your master project well we have we
have to prove uh Lego did me wrong and
they really me so this is a way
to get back at them
okay
sweet how long did that take you to make
um I I personally didn't build this
um Ian how long would you say it took
uh this came from Lego Allison we have
our Instagram uh in the dock there Lego
design Allison she is extraordinary very
talented she is she lives in Bree's leg
she's bricked up she's bricked up she's
freaked the up
and so Zach you actually got in touch
with her through your mutual love of
Lego correct she she messaged me and
she's like hey if you ever want anything
custom Lego wise
um let me know and Ian and I were
talking about this idea of
doing something podcast Lego related and
um
I was like what is this it's us right
now
we uh we reached out to her and um
we got it done this is incredible uh and
the impossible things are happening here
in the H3 podcast probable things
impossible things all the best I mean
the attention to detail on this set is
Ian you were saying the dimensions are
exact yeah I uh measured the studio and
sent it to her so it is uh to scale yes
that is incredible we have a gallery of
uh up close as well in the dock
um yeah the details on a lot of the
figures are amazing we should take a
look through that so go check out we'll
put the link in the description Ally
song Ally song Ally Allison Gail bricks
and close enough
Ali hold on Ali song Ally bricks
it's there
it's just a different interpreter song
oh you're right it is Ali song okay oh
it says ale bricks
okay
a true artist
yeah so uh and also there's one other
link someone to thank uh James uh James
input brick uh he made all of the
Minifigures Minifigures of uh so he made
custom bricks yeah he had to make those
customers holy smoke shout out to both
of the both Allison and James so you are
part of a vibrant Lego Community there's
a lot of Lego love out there for Lego
Lou and um although the girl at the
store didn't seem to know who you were
that was weird it was probably uh maybe
you went to the wrong store
it's I at HQ you know they told me they
were gonna have a whole brick carpet and
it might have hurt a little bit but it
was a bricked carpet it must be new it
must be new she doesn't know like we got
it taken care of yeah yeah yeah she she
just oh so it's her fault
it wasn't that you're unknown it's just
that she she's new and such an amateur
and frankly
she's gone we took care of it it's done
it's dealt with it's in the hands of the
Lego we don't call them Gods we call
them lot the Lego Lords yeah uh this is
input brick also incredible Lego uh God
so how does he do it he makes these tiny
custom Legos like what it's it's
unbelievable so here is there a video of
him doing it
is he
it's just them twirling
and this community is so um
there's so much communication going on
with about like the next set like what
what's coming out next for Lego
um
everyone loves building I know Ian can
relate
um Ian's a new Builder he's bricked up
um you caught the uh the bug
you muted
oh
yeah I just cooked one up in the back
here so the best just now
he got that pirate gift there we go look
at that free one you get with the
purchase right so you were making them
while you were switching don't worry
about it
where do you think I get the time to
build all these sets
you guys are building Legos at work I
don't know how I feel about that yeah
really I mean do what you want on your
own time but Legos at work that seems
extracurricular extracurricular
um well here's the most exciting part we
have submitted this design
to the official Lego website
where people can vote
on if it should be
a set or not and I guess ours isn't
alive yet to vote on it's taking a
little time to uh process
um but it should be up uh
hopefully very soon and what does that
mean if it if it uh wins does that mean
that they're gonna what does that mean
you can buy it there's a lot of factors
that go into it just fair warning but um
if you reach 10 000 supporters on The
LEGO Ideas website it get there's
different tiers you get into so we get
past the first tier the second tier is
Lego
is like can we actually make this you
know deals with licensing and all that
fun
I don't see any over ten thousand not
even close to be honest
I think with the power of the fupa
Troopers we could get there so we're
gonna get this set in Lego stores around
the world that is the Hope with a big
picture of Zach's face on the cover
finally respect you they'll find those
I'm on the Lego
box yeah who I am I'm Lego I'm the
of the Walk baby so we aren't officially
approved yet though is that the problem
uh it says it should it should go
through hopefully by the end of the day
we really have a link okay okay so we'll
blast that out when we have it uh Grace
has an interesting theories act she's
she speculates maybe
she's pretending not to know who you are
because you didn't ask her how her day
was going
[Music]
[Laughter]
to consider that here's some close-ups
so you guys can appreciate actually the
the intricacy
the craftsmanship
I mean this custom Lego Masterpiece it's
unbelievable
look at this masterpiece yeah I forgot
to mention not an oversight but uh
lovebot he uses his very own Lego too
just uh you know it's just really
amazing what uh and I don't I don't
think the world of Lego is gonna recover
from this for a long time
I think that uh definitely not well you
know about Mr Gold right
no is that Mr Gold is the it's almost
the fairy tale of the Lego world it's
the uh Holy Grail if you will Mr Gold
was so popular and they only made a
certain amount of these Minifigures that
uh the Lego Community was divided and
went crazy we don't really like to speak
at those times but um
Mr Gold it's a cool dude wait what
where's that we even have the the
um epoxied meat Mountain yes I mean what
the hell and then here's lovebot
an actual Lego piece what is gold man
can I get some gold Mr Gold Mr Gold
Mr Gold toys for sale what's the what is
the issue here they go for a lot of
money this is 25 those are fake those
are fake see replica
custom replica 25 is a lot in the Lego
world that's true for one figure like
here hold on all right okay here's a
real one 350.
here's the article about uh Mr Gordon
there
um
that is pretty fire
so what's the deal with Mr Gold only 5
000 of them were ever made that's that's
why so if people went crazy for it
um
dark times for Lego world why would dark
because we were divided everyone wanted
it people were I mean
Bloodshed in the streets for it but have
you got your hands on on a Mr Gold yet I
have not
I don't feel I'm worthy yet no okay
it's not that bad 350 I mean you bought
a Rolex I mean that could be a uh a uh
you think that's real I feel like that's
too low no it's a fugazi like if you go
back like I saw one for like 25
000 really twenty five thousand dollars
dude I'm telling you dark times that Mr
Gold Lego man sold for sure one for 5K
there here it is in the original pack
for four thousand four hundred I'm
skeptical of the office this is the
original pack number four three two one
look
look at the price over time on brick
economy.com
I can't see the numbers on the left
what's the price we're looking at yeah
we're looking at the current price
uh
I mean this is this one here for 4 000.
39. you've got to be a PSA one or a ten
there you guys gotta be rated this is
this is the real deal Zach yeah and may
I suggest Maybe
a medallion uh Mr Gold Medallion kind of
the clout yourself up like a necklace do
you remember when uh uh Lil Uzi got the
piercing on his forehead yeah that's
what I would do in Mr Gold okay I like
that idea
I'd put it right there you know everyone
to see
um because it's it's a status symbol
um here's one 25
000. it's a high quality okay but let's
be honest looking at Brick economy
there's not been one sold over four
thousand it's a little a little
overpriced yeah they're asking too much
it's a 9.5
um
I mean that's good that's that's real
good maybe it's the fact that it's
certified like that it's just this one
gold figurine correct Mr Gold huh
there's also the the the the funny thing
is the the sets go for a lot of money
the Rarity of them are the rare sets but
there's also the the Minifigs people go
crazy for like there's a a Yoda I heart
New York minifig that goes for a lot of
money too
um minifig yeah I love New York yeah
miniature figurine yeah can you pull
that up for me Yoda Lego I love New York
now this one Jack is 400 bucks and maybe
it's just
not in great shape maybe it's possible
it's not sealed
um
I don't know this could be yours I'm
just saying you know it's true I I just
I question the validity of it you know
yeah brick economy has this one for uh
let's see that is so dumb I'm sorry it's
just Yoda with the I Heart New York
shirt what do you mean that's epic thank
you love yo I gotta get me one of these
I need this right now if I could have
one Lego of all the Legos and I have
zero right now it'd probably be yoda
wearing the I Heart oh it's pretty silly
it's pretty good honestly the Minifigs
it's a little much I will I will say
it's it's a lot
you know what
I I I'm a fan because it says New York I
love instead of I love New York the way
Yoda talks oh New York I'm in right New
York I love it that changes it so so
what is this going for
uh this one wasn't as much as it it
looks like it's around three grand three
grand whoa that's a steal that's a steal
boy love is all bricked up can we go
back to love yes
oh this is very exciting can I started
like top pieces okay so we have
something to Aspire to Mr Gold but for
me personally I I would prefer to have
the sets
um there's like
rare Death Star sets like the Star Wars
is really in high demand okay
um like Lego Death Star that's out of
production
um some of the Star Destroyers are a lot
of money what are we talking here a
couple Grand 2500 3000
how do Legos hold in a recession do they
hold their value like gold
I'm not really stepping into the uh
collector end of the market on it
because I build it I take it out of the
box right which I I do it for Pure
enjoyment right I call it therapy all
jokes aside Lego therapy Lego therapy
right layer P
um I find it soothing I find it relaxing
and it's just you know
yeah I've heard that um actually Legos
hold their value better than gold so as
far as Investments go
it's actually more valuable pound for
pound than gold itself is that so yeah I
heard that well they got best in both
worlds with uh Mr Gold so you got a Lego
and gold Mr Gold you know what's funny
is a solid piece of gold in the shape of
Lego gold Mr gold is worth less
that's just proof right there yeah
I think Legos frankly if you're asking
me is the currency of the future I agree
with that I mean crypto buy go
itself I think the US dollar needs to be
backed by Lego bricks my Lego economy
we're bricked up Lego is a Danish
company right
yeah
that's a problematic how about that
we're gonna have to look into that
America needs to invade Denmark
I agree I agree yeah we've been working
on that for a long time on Swedish
people
when we push them out like from the
bottom of our Island we stopped we let
them have the little Island right yeah
the problem is it's like that's nice of
you America we need to own the means of
production like that's why we're in
we're constantly invading Middle East so
we need to own those factories
Americans need to be on the phone well
the US dollar is going to be back by
Lego I mean come on
the Danes well the cool thing now
[Music]
issue oh we got a technical issue can
you all fix that or is that like a
technical issue it's a technical issue
okay hold on just a little technical
issue here we have some technical issue
it sounds like what do we do about it
what are we gonna do
wait you hit the button yeah why do you
do that
oh my God Queen you censored yourself
I just got too close that's amazing
that's really amazing I just got two
clothes we're not you know I'm not
trying to give anyone more for the
Highlight Reel it's a good day you know
what I mean yeah yeah
just watch Hamlet
well thank you thank you again I want to
give a shout out to Allison to James the
Ian to Sam to
um
the person at the LEGO store was very
Jokes Aside very helpful she was a fan
of the show
um we didn't want to get her in trouble
so we blurred her face um I heard you
guys had an interesting experience at
the LEGO store at first they weren't
gonna let you film inside they clocked
us right at the door and then you guys
found an opening yes
um again I won't say how because I don't
want to incriminate this person but we
uh
we got it done
they got it done we got it done and and
Danes I hope you're watching we're gonna
get it done too
[Laughter]
thank you uh Zach and thank you everyone
and everybody involved in producing this
master thank you thank you for a peek
into your world we're all fascinated by
the Lego world that Zach inhabits Lego
yeah put some respect on the name
sorry don't do the weird staring thing
to me oh
please
Zach I can't do this right now
Lou is offended uh he's walking off
yikes
I'm telling you man maybe check for any
Lego pressure cookers that dude's
unhinged
all right great job everybody what a fun
time huh hell yeah that was awesome hell
yeah y'all been cooking that one up for
a minute all jokes aside it took forever
to I it was actually insanely difficult
and took forever to make that Lego set
so
it's real
it's real it's happening
there it is
one more can be said
now I know about Mr Gold
would you say that's the most valuable
Lego Zach I'd say minifig yeah
what's the most valuable Lego I'm
curious I'm seeing most value brick
economy once again
oh wow San Diego Comic-Con Spider-Man
sixteen thousand
wait what's special about this this
seems like pretty like standard fare you
could only get it at that specific event
if they don't make Spider-Man Legos they
do but it it's the special Comic-Con one
and you had to win a raffle while you
were there but what is special about it
does it look different that's probably
it looks like you're different
it's a little bit of a different
Spider-Man so it's so expensive yeah
that's how Lego does not make sense to
me no I mean I love
a lot of Collectibles are like that like
a lot of the Star Wars figures from the
80s like some of them that have any kind
of like defect those are the most
expensive okay all these like beanie
babies too I guess all these top ones
are from San Diego Comic-Con 2013. that
one was lit bro
these are all from uh the top three
you've got Green Arrow
the word probably the worst superhero
what's with superheroes that just shoot
a bows this list is garbage you're not
getting the top
have you heard of the solid gold cp3o
what's that like a like over a hundred
thousand dollars that's a good one love
I don't see it on brick economy
yeah it's too much of a juicer yeah well
we'll send it to me
I've been uh to give Lego uh an idea
other than the H3 podcast set I would
like to see more C-3PO from them yeah
here is top 10 most okay so this is
Brick fact
so they made a solid gold 14k C-3PO in
2007.
it's sold for 200 000.
now we're talking but it was solid gold
which is a mistake frankly because the
plastic is more valuable
Ninjago movie
wooden piece
guys let's make the Legos from the Lego
material it you can't make right the
most valuable ones and not use the
patent Lego technology
wood you know white gold to stop it
solid silver you know and platinum I'm
not impressed
I want bricks
not
metal right Zach
we're bricked up
black Superman suit this one seems Lego
and it's 4400 there's only 200 of these
made also two thousand also yo 2013 San
Diego Comic-Con bro
you had to be there those were the days
man legendary it's like Woodstock for
Lego
that was a crazy year for them man
oh here here it is yeah 2013 Comic-Con
San Diego
what a year
me man
well there it is another one San Diego
Comic Con 2013 Azog
a year
nobody's seen a year like that and Lego
hitting brick history
what year is it I know it's not 2013 is
it what
laughs all right thank you guys
our friends of the show young gravy took
a bit of a spill
uh and this one I'm this was 100 the
venue's fall I mean what the they
got him walking on watch his feet this
wood plank just goes up
and he never had a chance
that boy hit the ground hard too I'll
tell you
like that
[Applause]
[Music]
hard to recover from that but he did
he did
[Applause]
that people were really worried oh
[Music]
good man gravy he's a good man that
gravy
yeah one more time just for posterity
I mean what do you do yeah I get bitched
to the well he broke one of his wrists
and then he broke the other elbow what
he got yes yeah yeah yeah yeah what in
this clip and he like pushes himself off
the ground with his arm all I can think
about is the fact that it's like broken
he broke two bones so so the venue's got
to be that was super messed up
like why did that word come up on him uh
oh super messed up
okay well get paid I guess gravy
that's the I've been listen I've never
seen a walkway for the artist that is
this up it must have been like it
rained the night before and it was all
muddy so they just quickly threw down
some plywood but like at least fasten it
down yeah obviously that was a bad idea
[Applause]
disappointed too because it's like I see
oh somebody took a fall at a spill and
took a spill at a festival I mean this
is like our favorite genre of videos but
that one it wasn't even that satisfying
I can't yeah I just my heart goes out to
him yeah
because it wasn't even his fault you
know right usually they're just not
paying attention they're getting lost in
the moment there's a hole in the stage
which is debatable if it's their fault
around but there's a hole in the
stage which is funny on its own
but that one poor gravy he finished the
show too Legend wow what a guy
shout out to him Friends of the show got
up
you know my throat's starting to hurt
again it's like not getting better stop
you want stop it yes I would love throw
coat thank you I'm gonna have to like if
it doesn't get better in a couple days
I'm gonna have to like I'm getting an
endoscopy
right you were talking about that
yesterday on see you next Tuesday my
doctor recommended it I don't have it
scheduled yet but I'm gonna do it
you know it's like it's freaky
it's crazy and then apparently I learned
people get colonoscopies and endoscopies
at the same time and the cameras meet in
the middle and kiss
because I learned that the endoscopy
they go down your esophagus into your
stomach in Chapel right yeah they go
into your stomach and then into your
small intestines right I was like what
the they're going into my
intestines that means that when they
pull it out there's on it there's
no way you don't get in your mouth
well sure you know then it starts to
become a philosophical question when
does food become you know what I
mean right it's because it's at a stage
of decomposition when does life become
life yeah I mean
in a way all food is we're all
eating all the time
well on the Spectrum everything is
turning well hold something else hold on
changing on the spectrum of it when does
food become I mean food is on the
far end of of the Spectrum right
but it's like you know like the concept
of like potential energy and physics
yeah yeah so there's like a lot of
potential
sure
I understand yeah yeah
let's see if that's related though
you're just not thinking on a high
enough plane I don't know what to say
thank you so much
um but yeah so I that blew my mind that
the camera goes into the small
intestines and I says well that's funny
because the colonoscopy goes into your
intestines I bet there's a world where
the cameras can peep each other
and I wonder if they I wonder if they
even know angled when they get tied in a
little knot you know like oh dab up
and dab each other up well one thing I'm
like dude like a uh your shish
kebab at that point going straight
through it's a straight up uh
spit Rose yeah yeah
but one thing I thought is like if these
two teams aren't communicating I wonder
if like
the endoscopy doctor's like what is that
in there there's something really
concerning in there and then the
colonoscopy doctors like there is
something really concerning coming out
of your stomach
and then they operate on you they never
they never they don't ever talk to each
other then they operate with the
assumption that there's this okay
whatever I'm going
a weird name Paul
throat Cub thank you for the gifted I
was just trying to figure out and not
hypothetical is your mouth in one room
and then the rest of you in another room
why don't the doctors know each other
there's one of those um
I see there's a divider yeah yeah
because the colonoscopy team in the
endoscopy team they generally don't get
along
yeah and big rivalry that's the classic
Dynamic yeah yeah they they're
constantly uh fighting
at the Hospitals and Clinics they don't
like it I was hoping they would connect
sort of make you like a Ethan schwartama
you know what I mean Ethan schwarma yeah
put my ass on a rack and barbecue me
I don't actually need a colonoscopy
though but that that just blew my mind
so
yeah it sucks
but um
let me talk about uh Dumb and Dumber
I've I've held my talk great movie let
me just talk and of course I'm talking
about Babylon preach Dumb and Dumber all
right well let me um get the stopwatch
set up here now guys before I know a lot
of you guys don't want to hear it
and I get that but just stay with me
it's gonna be fast I mean these guys
when someone goes publicly and says
about you
that like you were doing blackface
you're kind of obligated to respond and
I've learned that the hard way right
[Music]
now obviously some stuff is you know I I
did that right
but other stuff's kind of crazy how
they're how they're reaching so bear
with me please okay now hold on I the
timer didn't start you definitely
started no I'm setting it up you're
wasting time right now no Dan stop the
timer
stop the timer okay I wanted to do it
where's I forgot to to tell Zach so I'm
going to talk about something else Zach
and then you play the squeaking sound
got it yeah
so anyway did you guys see that Jack in
the Box used my sound
what crazy huh so fake wait
oh no not the squeaking
I don't want to talk about them
oh this is the bit we're in the bit now
I don't want to talk about Babylon reach
but they're uh why are they always
showing up at this time
I get it you guys okay all right fine
I'll talk about it
that was the bit
please clap
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we have to restart the timer and
now at this point we're definitely going
to need you to restart the timer
serious I've pledged to keep it under 10
minutes but Dan you got to be fair to me
okay don't be a hater s okay can I start
it now
I couldn't properly re-upload these I
mean I couldn't uh timestamp them so I
think you should have a couple more
minutes I'm just saying right talking
about I just I'm just saying what
because I'm saying he's right just a
couple because hold on
hold on hold on they erased the video
because they're cowards and losers and
they can't like stand behind anything
they say they're such losers what are
you saying dumb and dumber over there
man
uh squeaky and Babylon squeaks
the more I watch Babylon squeak I
realize how much reach has in common
with coconuts and Barbados like they are
this they are so similar
um so anyway yeah they uploaded a video
about me
that they erased after a few hours
and I'm here here they show so they says
H3 loves black people
and uh half the video their response to
our three four hour podcast three and a
half hour podcast
is basically to just call me racist they
literally didn't respond to anything I
said which is exactly what I predicted
they would do just straight up straw man
argue about something that I wasn't even
ever talking about
but here's what they're doing straight
off the bat this is a charcoal mask
now I always see like create unhinged
haters trying to say it's blackface
but there really are horrible stuff I've
said and done I don't see why you all
need to put like this dumb fake
blackface thing like I don't see why
y'all need to make that some kind of
point
it's literally a charcoal mask like why
are they acting so uh social justice
Warrior by the way uh trigger warning to
to uh Babylon reach charcoal mask
uh I'm typing you just looks stupid
no you look stupid
you made me defend this dude
okay guys trigger warning to Babylon
reach this is uh charcoal masks
these guys talk about sensitivity but my
God I mean let's it's just charcoal
so they're doing that also I think
they're trying to say something about
Jeff's haircut on me being racist
people were theorizing
uh but
but I just have curly hair I don't know
what to tell you guys I gotta explain
that
so
so anyway let's get into the the
response now it was like 20 it's 24
minutes long I'm not gonna respond to
the whole thing because the whole thing
is pretty much just silly and
not them not responding so let's see uh
there is a moment at 12 40 where they
have this great moment
when Olivia was popping off
um
and they played sad violin over her
really classy and again this is just a
classic response you know what I mean
they're like yeah well
if you think that's crazy listen to her
with sad violin over her women be trying
to ruin men's lives it's quite it's just
what they do I'm gonna go out of my way
to lie I don't like him so I'm just
gonna go lie about him assaulting me
that is such an insanely hurtful thing
to say about any woman ever it's a very
humiliating experience to go through
something like that and for for anyone I
haven't even seen this this was honestly
insane when I watched this my jaw just
dropped I was like are you all trying to
prove everything I said right that's so
it's just first of all I am so much
younger than they are it's really
embarrassing that they're participating
in this discourse specifically but if
they can put out a million videos being
like no I can speak from my perspective
because I have like people I know have
been falsely like if you think that you
have stance in this conversation so do I
okay so I can talk about what it's like
and I'm not going to play violin under
whatever story you're gonna tell
but no of course not because listen on
this show to be totally fair we we don't
engage when I did that podcast
we didn't engage in these silly
arguments and like avoiding stuff like
we actually talked about things which
they're incapable of doing because
they're Dumb and Dumber I mean they
really are real quick first golf Queen
second Dan didn't pause the timer when
she was talking dancing stop the timer
stop the timer stop it okay we need to
have a sidebar
now
if Olivia's talking and she has every
right to Dan that should not sap me of
my 10 minutes to discuss this are you
trying to silence her then
if you don't know who Olivia is she's
the leader who spends all her Day on
Reddit boards and thinks that's research
okay is that you Dan is that what you
think about Olivia is that you know what
I'm starting to agree with Rich Lux I
gotta say Dan is jealous of me
you're all saying that Olivia what
Olivia has to say isn't worth any time I
I that's what all of you are saying I
respect what Olivia has to say it seems
like it's valuable enough yeah I'm
sitting in the conversation since all of
you think that Olivia I'm saying no I'm
saying a man shouldn't be allowed to
allocate some time to her she could have
as much she could only speak when you
say yeah right then no I I didn't
stop let's stay we're staying focused
Dan you know in football they have
overtime or the extra time that's what
we're doing that's the sun sunrise
football soccer yes yes they do wow
you're a okay so so now we're the
timer is getting being increased to 12.
okay that's just that's just logical so
you can go ahead but we got extra
minutes on the clock okay and especially
your grandstanding you know should get
extra time for that too thank you for
the time
all right so here we go I can't stand
Dan Dan he's jealous of me
damn is jealous of me I love him so much
block me all right all right so here it
is here it is that like someone claiming
being a victim or surviving something is
foreign
once again their trademark uh we're
gonna laugh instead of actually making a
substantive well it's also I I'm keeping
in mind that they're not like Amber
Heard was was added after they're just
laughing at me
they were looking at Amber Heard when
they were giggling they're not giggling
at their joke they made they're giggling
at literally me talking I think you you
didn't hear close enough did you hear
what the floor said oh no it's here
she said hello so so reach is shaking
his finger at at Babel let's get a
glimpse into his inner thoughts
right
that is interesting I didn't consider
that
so I think their point is they're like
oh well Amber Heard lied about stuff so
therefore all women are like let's not
trust anyone ever like we never said
that people don't lie you know what I
mean
so weird also just why are we bringing
up other women and starting new
conversations let's talk about this and
let's stop laughing at me because it's
so ridiculous thank you
[Laughter]
that is so incredibly wrong and inform
and uninformed that like you one million
percent should not be making content
about this because you're teaching young
men who don't know anything about this
and then you're telling young women to
not talk to each other to not talk to
anyone to not tell anyone that something
happened because idiots like you and you
know what you I love that they played
your whole statement yeah which was
poignant I do hear what I said and I
still agree with it they don't respond
right they actually don't even respond
to it and that that's that's the
consistent thing you'll notice through
this I know they did respond they said
there's somebody
uh I'm gonna actually I'll play it from
here because uh it's all pretty good
from here this is all just like Ethan's
racist compilation and the thing so in
that compilation like the majority of it
is the PewDiePie
uh n-word controversy when I had um
idubbz on
and obviously you can this isn't about
Babylon so you could pause the you can
pause the timer
yeah this isn't about Babylon reach no
how is this not about this is about
their video no no no it's about the
PewDiePie items thing yeah it wasn't
involved in that no so the reason I
because idubbbz came on the show a long
time ago his catchphrase was at the time
N word f word as he discussed in his
recent apology video and at the time I
was like how do you get away with saying
this word and then I said it
which was obviously
incredibly dumb and wrong and horrible
and you know my my father the framing
was how do you get away with that when
now it haunts both yeah he could the
answer was he doesn't and neither do you
so there you go
um and I said it a lot because I was
like oh I'm saying this word I'm saying
this word so when they put together
compilation it looks like
it's all from the same instance in that
case does it make it better I'm just
saying like yeah I got you and so um
am I really not counting this time no
this no no this is a different topic you
know okay
but some of the stuff in their
compilation is actually super up
they took when I was doing the members
live yesterday someone was like what was
the deal with the Unga Bunga one that
one seemed super up and I was
like I don't remember saying that off to
go back and watch and what they did
but is they cut out me reading they're
definitely talking about them I mean
you're literally referring to them right
okay at this point okay
what they literally did was cut out me
reading super racist comments on the
Joey salads video that I criticized that
was one of the first times that I really
alienated myself from my audience to
call out Joey salads for doing the super
racist super fake prank where he put a
trump card in the hood
and then all of a sudden like 10 black
dudes just come out like a street
fighter bonus round and start breaking
it with her boob coming out and I was
like this is so racist and so obviously
fake my and a lot of the fans got super
angry about it and I looked at the
comments on Joey's video I was like look
how up this is I was reading the
super racist comments
a lot of them had n-word and you know
obvious again I shouldn't have said that
it's up that I said that
but for them to cut that out and then
make it seem like I said it is crazy
because listen I've done and said things
that are up you don't even need
to make it up I don't know why y'all are
trying so hard and it's just it's
up right I mean in that case I was
actually
like he had paid those people to come
break the car or whatever and then just
lied and said oh this just happened
naturally right yeah and then
insane and then and then someone who was
in an apartment building overlooking it
you can stop the timer
someone was in an apartment building
overlooking filmed them setting it up
wow and then I was like I told
you guys this was fake you racist pieces
of
and um
they clipped me talking about that to
make it seem like I was saying horribly
racist things which is really up
of them frankly
and they did that a few times now my
theory at the time which was
insane and wrong is that
if I'm not using the word
in a malicious way if I'm not using it
as an insult if I'm just talking about
the word
then I can say it
and obviously uh that was super ignorant
and not something I would ever do today
but
it's yeah it's super up you know
what I mean and so
I'm not even mad that they rolled the
clip because I said those things
I did those things and I'm happy to own
it I'm you know I'm happy to talk about
as many times as I need to
to explain
how I up right
and how I I'm sorry for what happened
right I'm not trying to hide from it
I'm just being straight up like yeah I
said I said those things so
um I'll talk about it as many times as I
need to right that was me up
and a lot of them are and you know and
here's me trying to evolve into a into a
better
uh person right
and so it's super underhanded of them to
that I didn't even say
you know that just really is sad
obviously I'm not going to play the mega
compilation because
I'm sure we'll get demonetized or
age-restricted probably because it's
just fan word
um but uh I just wanted to touch on that
and it's the same thing with saying I
did blackface it's like come on guys
just stick to the facts at least because
the facts are bad enough you know what I
mean they're bad I admit that man it
looks bad
as I'm not even mad about uh I can't
even complain that they did it frankly
because that's what happened you know
what I mean but it's not by the way a
response to my criticism is not to say
well you're racist therefore
um
Therefore your opinion is invalid that's
a weird that's a weird take what is the
leading theory for why they took it down
okay so they removed it yeah I have a
few theories
well here let me go on and then we'll
theorize because one of my theories oh
yeah and here dude this was look at this
did you when I was reading the Joey
salads comment that I was talking about
they isolated the audio from the video
and made it seem like some found footage
made it sound grainy and stuff so so to
obscure from where it came and me with
the charcoal mask to make it seem so
much worse too like somebody this is
somebody who maliciously intentionally
has knowingly cut this clip out of a
video where I was criticizing racist
people and put it in to depict the
opposite you know that's crazy to me
it's from a video why why just pull the
audio you know what I mean it's
up so uh let yeah the if that video is
public still I mean you can find it I
could draw your attention to the screen
with the timer on well I have 12 minutes
so chill okay
so at 18 minutes
there's another one we're not right now
yeah okay stop they start making fun of
my Tourette's which is pretty wild
that's whenever you know I literally
said that but because
Ethan's gonna even we got this anyway so
you have the tape I don't know how it's
not that hard to understand the
difference between
engine
and gender are two different things are
you guys listening I'll explain it
sex is your biological warning stop the
timer
I'm talking about sex and gender what's
that got to do with them
this is their video this is my video
we're watching their videos nope this is
my video this is the deleted video I
don't see them all I see behind me thank
you
gender assigned at Birth
all right now I don't give a
correct happened can you pull up he has
Tourette's I don't give a
sure
I mean all right
whenever you're more they didn't get a
strike for this right no it's set okay
it says it was removed by user clearly I
mean here I have the they have like
gotten a warning from their YouTube rep
or something like hey you gotta pull
this down I don't I just don't get my my
guess would have been one of these two
moments the Olivia Amber Heard or
because like I know YouTube's policy
like being like oh he has a disability I
don't give a I'm gonna make fun of
it like that's like definitely in terms
of policy this one for sure right in my
experience as someone who's got a ton of
strikes they just give you the strike
they don't be like yeah but
[Music]
um uh can you send me the the screenshot
and the part that's up is that
like
if you go to the comments section of
this video which is a race or their
second video which is dumb and pointless
it's just pure anti-Semitism like 50
anti-semitism
and um I Unearthed the video these guys
are actually just deeply deeply
anti-semitic it turns out
uh which I which I'll show you guys if
you want to see that'll that's post
timer so we'll have to do a poll on that
uh I personally find it interesting but
uh we'll we'll you guys are in the power
of that
um
do you have that screenshot but I've
seen a ton of cons like
anti-semitic comments like Ethan pulled
his special Jewish strings with YouTube
it literally says removed by user
and somehow I'm being blamed
for them removing the video
they're saying I copyright strike that
and then they don't explain it either so
they leave it totally open for their fan
their anti-semitic fans who just draw
any psychotic conclusion about why they
removed it why wouldn't they explain it
at least in their second I'm seeing in
the chat that apparently last night on a
stream they said they removed it because
and I'm just reading the chat here they
didn't want the smoke that is okay
that's a that's a that's a joke that has
been going on they say Joaquin said this
on the stream and they say uh these nuts
in are it's like a Deez Nuts joke
they definitely did not say they don't
want the smoke I mean why would they say
that
here is um
here is a reach not making fun of my
Tourette's
this could be a good this is a good new
profile picture for me
[Laughter]
this is totally me when I'm having a
Tourette's
where's the CL you guys can't find the
screenshot it's above the picture cam
sent
okay
uh yeah so here's the uh conspiracy
theories why did the video get taken
down WTF he used his Israeli special
attack Ethan has friends at YouTube
because he belongs to a special group
that gets different rules than us
there's a country there's a country in
the Middle East full of people like
Ethan the comments are all straight
anti-Semitism he's this crazy Israeli
clown comedian come on Jordan I'm not
Israeli even
every Jew is just Israeli to you
um but uh Israeli citizen
okay whatever splitting hairs
Jews
splitting hairs here
uh here here this is the joke they say
ayo to everyone in the comments section
writing for
uh Abba and preaches dick over a video
of themselves they thought should be
deleted you're doing too much do better
you Gremlins this guy says so where did
they admit because that was taken down
as if that is the only reason a video
can be taken down they literally called
in
and said it on uh pekines
live stream going to have to be a bit
more specific than that search packing
didn't bring up someone with a live
stream can you tell me more he says yeah
bro just search up packing both of these
nuts in your mouth got him
I thought you'd like that one love yeah
that was pretty good but no where's the
screenshot of it says deleted by user uh
nuts
I believe you no I want I need to show
it because someone at least between the
two of us what's the timer someone needs
to show receipts the timer is done okay
we're we're not sticking to the timer no
we are
you're already a minute over yeah
I think we should restart it yeah
here is the here is the message video
unavailable video was removed by
uploader okay so it's like
they intentionally leave it open that
somehow allow people just to blame me
like I did some
but here they are talking about my
Tourette's so he needs to
find at Birth
I don't give a correct happen
whenever you're more stressed so he
needs to he he he's flaring up right now
yeah fair enough right now because it's
just I got ex I gotta explain that
yeah reach is dumb is flaring up right
now Jesus Christ he better he's better
you should take a note from coconut and
Barbados and just quiet down
you know what I mean
I'm a hidden bigger but I gotta explain
that bruh I'm not laughing at you to
read I'm laughing about the fact that
you're getting right you look stressed
right now yeah cause you said that
was easy now again I don't care people
been making fun of my Tourette's forever
I'm a public figure it's so obvious
right so what happens all the time it's
just ironic to me that they're going to
pull all this silly some some not silly
but a lot silly accusations of me being
racist well
calling me restarted in this video or
they said the restarted word and he's
like
imitating my disability they always use
it I've seen it three or four times he
tried to make a point he's like yeah I
can say restarted what but at the same
time if you're gonna add say like oh
don't uh use this word against this
marginalized group and I'm not saying it
says bad okay or maybe I don't I'm not
the I'm not the authority on to say
which is worse or what whatever I'm not
even make that comment but if you're
gonna say restarted and make fun of my
disability in the same video that
doesn't make a lot of sense you're not
keeping the same energy you want to
explain let's hear this restart the
timer
because he made fun of my Tourette's
from zero but also to add on to that
it's funny how in the previous video
babies talking stop the timer please yes
please go ahead ABC speak German
sometimes so if you give me some Runway
uh yeah also they talk about in the
previous video how you are trying to fit
this narrative when the girl called in
that you know you were misleading just
so that it fits your narrative whatever
the hell they were saying it's like
that's exactly what they're doing in
this video with the clips they showed
you know dude everything they do just
pure hypocrisy it's it's wild I mean
there's no excusing things you said and
you've acknowledged them before yeah of
course and like I said I'm happy to
acknowledge them as many times as I need
to because obviously if I have fans or
even people who know about me and they
hear that they're gonna think that it
sounds really bad and they're right
right so I should
have to explain myself as many times as
I need to okay but my problem is them
lying
because the they pulled is like
super super super super racist and I
didn't say that
right restart the timer for ableism
Cracker smoker says
hey let's go
different things are you guys listening
I'll explain it
sex is your biological
gender assigned at Birth there's female
and male all right now let's go on to
the more the other part which I think
you're having a lot of trouble with
gender
gender is how people Express themselves
as a social
constructive definition again let's just
laugh
because he went on this rant about women
are women dude I don't care if they're
trans or biological or gender I don't
see a difference so let's not engage
with the conversation let's just laugh
and act like it's the point is silly
when someone tries to look like
uncomfortable I'm very comfortable can I
comment on reaches uh he has a very
interesting fashion style it's like he
puts on everything in his closet at once
and heads out like if you look at their
videos this dude just puts on everything
in his house it's awesome and
listen I'm not one to uh criticize
fashion
uh because listen I'm not the best
dressed guy in the world but
I gotta explain that you gotta be
hot man I kind of like his outfits can I
just say yes
it's just like uh pretty cool
yeah it looks like he's ready to take on
a riot or something because he's wearing
like right here Riot sheep okay this one
maybe this fits a little weird but
usually he he's he's got pretty no no
you guys should should definitely see
how he dresses this man is just putting
on his whole damn closet and it's
awesome this reminds me when you're
joining like a bicycle gang they gave
you a prospect Faith at first before he
did an actual cut that's sort of oh he's
in Hell's Angels
Prospect
my agenda
okay brother
we are going to talk this okay gender
gender
was a geology gender you know gender
okay the same one I have no idea I if I
had to take a guess I think it is this
you are a transgender
I think that's what they're quoting
oh you think they're quoting that
preacher guy that's giving them a lot of
credit yeah I don't know maybe that's
just how my brain thinks but yeah no no
you're thinking sound bites that's true
I mean I'm proud of you for spotting
that gender is how people Express
themselves right as a social construct
and I said it real quiet so you guys
could hear
and on a spectrum people identify
uh with different genders based on how
they feel and how they want to express
themselves do you see that they're two
different things
he says he just said gender
and so you guys still don't understand I
said it's so slow that's what I did and
you guys even watched it you played the
clip but y'all still somehow don't get
it
yeah
and that's the extent of their
commentary
they really are dumb I I find it
interesting how reach
carries himself as some kind of
intellectual he's very dumb
I find that interesting I I don't know
that he ever learned how to dress
himself either I think that could be
uh stem from that
he just does it all and hopes that it
works out
it's people that like they they identify
with different things
yeah on the day of and the Spectrum and
how you express yourself according as in
gender you guys understand yeah it's
really simple this is why they're trying
to make it seem complicated
I see yeah
pretty interesting take by them good a
very cool uh uh Counterpoint they've
made a lot of researchers so
someone on a lie okay so that was that
and then there's just one more part I
want to play in the beginning they go on
to continue this is it I promise to
continue to defend uh fresh and fit in
the funniest way possible if you are
familiar with Ethan Klein
um and then I'm done podcast with his
wife Hassan super energy today
because my wife Hassan got him I
wish
I wish I could get my hands on his
girthy you in the song y'all are
gay gay
together me of doing
Hassan he's a lady he's gay and Ethan is
gay
gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay gay
gay gay super gay who is gay you're
holding gay together who is gay I feel
uh gay
podcast of Ethan Klein just kept my
lifespan by three years so we won't try
to make it through this that's not the
thing that uh the fresh and fit dudes
say about them all the time too which
kind of drives home your point that
they're really not that different
that that they're in a relation ab and
preach oh yeah they use that as a right
they're always saying that these guys
are gay and they're they use that
genuinely as an insult and they just did
it and they just they got so defensive
they literally got so defensive about us
comparing them to uh fresh and fit which
is great because
I think I struck a nerve yeah there's so
many weirded yeah they're nasty and you
know what's kind of interesting I and
you you can stop the timer because this
is a this is a sidebar
I learned some lore about Abba and fresh
and fit they used to be homies Abba went
on fresh and fit got clouded up by them
they had a high viewed episode and they
were homies and they were cool they were
friends
and then a month after that of them
being homies and collabing and he
puts out a video
uh talking on fresh and fit and so
he snaked him in a sense he's like all
of a sudden you're homies and then
you're you just make a video blasting
them now of course they're wrong about
everything but I understand why Myron
who I'm sure doesn't have a lot of
friends
um got really upset when he thought Abba
who was probably just like one of like
his few friends in this world uh snaked
him so not so he's a snake too but you
know I mean they're right
yeah but then they laughed at Tourette's
and young girls getting raped so they're
still wrong
on the important issues they're just not
that different yeah she's the loser
feminist researcher who spends all her
Day on Reddit boards and thinks that's
research okay thank you
um
here's my husband by the way or wife
they got us
yes sir
yep you got me
just for you guys so you wouldn't have
to stay in the same fight so let's go
hey you Liars you cowards the thing
about them Babylon reach is that when
you look at them holistically you I
don't think they're that much different
than fresh and fit and in some cases
worse because I see them serving as a
Gateway into this really toxic
manosphere uh phobic misogynistic women
be lying type of thing they are fresh
and fit
did that hit too close to home for you
buddy
okay again what a response what a
poignant that was I mean the the
commentary they provide is unparalleled
we just described their bad date
and at one point she said that he lifted
up her top to see her breasts so now
they're talking about the fact that this
girl is fresh and she was insinuating
heavily implying something extremely
inappropriate happened okay they're
trying to say it's not that kind of
store she didn't she was just talking
about a bad date that's her story let's
listen let's check it out in this
narrative even though she said oh I
don't think he did a crime or whatever
listen the way you've said this story
the way that you guys have framed it the
fact that Ethan keeps implying it the
fact that most of the people the comment
it was one time it was literally one
time I said that's what he did we all
understand what you're framing okay you
can't say I didn't say he did that crime
he's so desperate to believe that but
it's just not true there was no framing
yeah it wasn't really even a crime
alleged it was just he's an embarrassing
loser oh wow hold up preach
classic commentary
do people realize I wonder if dude Their
audience realize that they're just
watching two dudes laugh
they're not they don't say anything
yo this is good this is good I'll tell
you
what is this video the thrust of the
call and who's framing when they're
titling their video fake me too
educations when that was it wasn't a me
too Alex it was I went on a pseudo date
with this weirdo right and it
was a horrible experience you have no
stories and she never claimed that he
did that she never claimed it
this this is a bad this is very bad
I mean at this point I did he lead with
tongue or no all that happened is that
you
know what's what's that was I said there
was one time and he framed it as a
question and then they showed the clip
of exactly that and what's interesting
they cut her saying no he didn't do he
didn't do a crime right and you being
like okay okay
but what's also interesting is that
Myron
straight up admitted that he did do this
and I posed them a direct question I
says what do you call it
if somebody goes up to a woman lifts up
their top to expose their breasts
without consent what do you call it
they will not answer that question
at one point because it seems like him
and her are on the same page on that
moment
said that sounds like that might be a
song and she said no I was one brief
moment where she said he lifted up her
top you didn't say that's a you said
that kind of sounds like a song I mean I
don't know it does kind of sound like
it's kind of funny because they're
they're like yeah but then they're
showing that we're right and then they
just laugh that and then Myron goes yeah
it happened and I made fun of her
lopsided titties too
Jesus insane like what again that clip
that they showed based off of what she
described I don't think it's that big of
a stretch for you to ask that question
he lifted up her shirt and she was very
uncomfortable that sound bad he
shouldn't have lifted up her shirt
that's crazy I didn't dispute
that I asked you guys what do you call
it if somebody lifts up somebody's top
to expose their best without their
permission there wasn't really even a
crime alleged is that just a joke
or is she just he's entitled to do
whatever he wants to her because it's 5
a.m there wasn't really even a crime
though yeah he did lift up her shirt and
look at her now if somebody does that
without your consent what is that it
wasn't a me too alligator
35 year old Myron's yeah being exposed
as being kind of cringe there was no
framing there wasn't really dude their
videos are insanely
can we stop please
this is the last part this is my last
part we're like 45 minutes into this
this is my last part this is my last
part
so they showed all that and their
response is breathtaking they go
they don't go
what do you call it when a when somebody
lifts your top without your consent
instead of answering that they say see
they did make allegations that was their
point
they're claiming that there wasn't
anything alleged or there wasn't any
framing yet in this very podcast they're
still framing it like this man
yeah guys why why is that silly is that
so weird if this young girl wanted to
it's up to her how she wants to classify
it for herself
why do they what Myron did is he did
reach forward and he pulled up her shirt
he admitted it sexually expose her he
did something bad it's up to her what
she wants to classify it as but it's
crazy to kind of insinuate that he
should have done it they it's so
interesting that they act like that is
so absurd they're like yeah that's
obviously not a crime
like what the
did he admit to doing you lift up
someone's shirt with other consent and
look at the
guys if you Google up the definitions
that fits right under yes exactly
Myron admit he literally admit to doing
it
how can they miss the point so hard
you know what Liz Ethan
I'm not even alleging or trying to frame
it that you're some kind of okay so so
and then here's the n-word compilation
where they
they forced that in to the video
uh so that's it
okay is everyone okay
now return to the question
why do we think they remove the video
right because that that is a somewhat of
a mystery
because it was fairly well received by
Their audience despite
the well not despite it's almost like uh
uh and coexisting with the incredible
amount of anti-Semitism in the comments
but they are so wanting to distance
themselves re-uploads are being removed
they do not want any of this on the
internet I'll leave that question up to
you to answer which implies to me
that they're embarrassed to some
capacity of either making fun of my
disability playing sad violin over
uh Olivia
or
basically acknowledging that they did
assault her
I don't know
but they are a bunch of losers
they can't even stand behind their own
goddamn video I mean what morons
uh so I don't know what do you I mean at
first I thought maybe it just got mature
rated or something and then they're like
oh if we can't make money from it we'll
just remove it but they're intentionally
vagueness around why they removed it is
very interesting I don't know if you
guys have any thoughts
all right
no thoughts
thank you
[Music]
thank you guys
appreciate that
um
yeah that's about it
now let's do a poll okay
and you guys are the here is me and my
uh wife by the way
on our special day oh
look how happy we are beautiful
do you are we not entitled to be happy
you know what I mean Love Is Love dude
here's reach's response
not awesome
[Music]
so cool
his commentary is so good
so uh let's do a poll do you guys want
to watch me prove that they're
anti-Semitic yes or no
uh it's gonna be a whole another 30
minutes of Babylon reach just being up
front if we spoke yes and then there's
no complaining
we're just going to embrace it
foreign
and it's very good I'll tell you guys
it's very good
I think the video is extremely
uh
extremely damning I was kind of my jaw
was kind of aghast
and Dan I hate to tell you that yes is a
winning at this moment
which did you vote on Dan
I created the poll so I can't vote but I
would definitely vote no
damn would vote no I mean you spent like
45 minutes on it on yesterday's episode
which I know is not for everybody but
listen when somebody does an n-word
compilation you gotta respond
it's just some it's just the way it is I
didn't have a choice
all that being said uh I'm I'm a man of
the people Dan
if you don't want it you better get your
votes in those
you better get your votes in
we are talking about anti-semitic
Babylon reach
they're defending they defending Kanye
saying Defcon going Defcon on all Jews
that's really good
and they're defending Kyrie whatever his
name is uh sharing Holocaust denial
books now what you guys want to do it
again because there's passion there's
passion in the comments the nose are
very passionate the yeses are very
passionate
we're absolutely torn on this topic of
Babylon reach
there's a bloodbath in the comments
okay let's restart the poll now that
people with their heads are clear I'll
give the nose another chance to win
because I see the passion so let's do it
one more time
do you want to see
Babylon reach defend Kanye West saying
basically death to all Jews
it's very interesting I'm telling you
guys are gonna like it it's not like
it's not going to be boring you guys are
going to like it it's good
[Music]
but I leave the power in your hands
do you want to see Babylon reach defend
Kanye West good pull Dan
do you want it okay no this is a bad
pull
wait was were they confusable for do you
want to see Babylon reach defend Kanye
West yes well now it's confusing because
this is the other way around but how
could it be so different the second time
I think a lot of people didn't read the
text and just clicked what they clicked
last time
but it was the same last time right yeah
I think it was the same exact same
okay good this is good I don't I don't
want to subject you guys to more
uh
this is very interesting I think we have
a bad pull here
[Music]
okay so here's what I'll do put a link
in the description so you guys can go
watch it it's uh called what is it
called you know I mean we won't watch it
Kanye West Abba and reach it's called Uh
Kanye West Jews why folks don't care
about anti-Semitism I love how they put
anti-Semitism in air quotes
so here it is can you put it in the
description for me Dan
sure this is our compromise okay
and I want to show you guys
they go Kanye Kyrie and the Jews why
folks don't care about quote
anti-semitism
that silly goofy thing that's not really
a thing
it's awesome this video is wild you guys
are gonna love it so go watch it
great
it's awesome
[Music]
okay there it is we've evaded
another
30 minutes
of Babylon reach
Dan is ecstatic
they're just boring dude I agree they're
just such a snooze Fest you know I'm
usually four a little bit of a drama and
like that but these they we don't
get they don't juice the views nobody
gives a about but they they don't
they don't even say anything what's
interesting that's exactly it it's like
there's there's not even like any meat
it's like we can only make fun of it or
creaky floor so many times it's like
they watch a clip and then they laugh
and then they imitate your voice and
then they watch another clip and it's
just
there's nothing they even
there's not there's no like argument to
to argue with it's just right boring
uh oh well here one thing I do want to
show just to read a few comments to show
you guys what kind of now I'll say this
about our audience
you can go through our videos anyone go
to the comment section there are you
will not see racist comments you will
not see homophobic comments you'll not
see anti-semitic transphobic comments
our fans I love
I'm very proud of the community that we
have uh
fostered here
and we just don't do that but and
this was part of my problem back when I
was this enlightened Centrist the
comments you see comments of people
saying super racist homophobic
anti-semitic and I got to the point
and the Joey salads one which they took
out of context to say I'm racist
was one of the first times I saw all the
comments I was like these are the people
that watch my videos
leaving like these insane like insane
racist comments and that's part of what
prompted the change but they don't have
that Enlightenment on the video about
quote anti-semitism
he Kanye has broken the show business
rules the rules of perception if they're
black it's a gang if they're Italian
small but if they're Jewish it's a
coincidence and you should never speak
about it Dave Chappelle these company
exists are really doing Jewish people a
disservice public sentiment went from
Kanye's wild Kanye's off his Med to
maybe Kanye's got a point
Kanye was punished for what
you can't bully and be the victim you
can't have both Jews are bullying the
whole premise in this is crazy straight
like Nazi propaganda
um you guys should watch it great point
from ABBA this isn't helping to reduce
Emma anti-Semitism it's galvanizing it
uh
ninety percent of people reacting to
Kyrie's Outburst now Kyrie
shared a documentary about Holocaust
denial it's just straight up
anti-Semitism it's about it's about Jews
Kyrie got canceled Dan what did he say
goes in search for the documentary let
me see what it's about watches it and
now supports Kyrie
they're like yeah the Holocaust didn't
happen
if baffles me help people are trying to
silence
and it's so hard there's they're just so
it's so up this video
but okay go watch it yourself
thank you
I'm done
have a good night have a good night then
we voted no okay all right what else we
got for you degenerates
hold on
okay go ahead
I just want to be left alone let's go
back to our Goofs and gaffs
James Charles has the longest snake in
the world
interesting what is the longest snake in
just kidding
um
looks like he just woke up what's the
longest snake in the world or something
that's an unusually puffy you know what
a like an eye style is sometimes you get
like a zit on your eyelid us it's called
a stye yeah wait look how up it
looks when I go back
this that doesn't look right
it looks like he has a stye
only bad people get sties
my sister used to get them every week
there you go I agree deeper look into it
people
just kidding
where did he put his tongue out loud
nasty he's nasty
dude this video is so sad volunteer LAPD
officer gets swarmed by bees
it's actually it's quite interesting the
whole way this video plays out
is kind of a fascinating social
experiment from the chopper down to his
partner who's just sitting there
watching fascinating stuff that's that's
what I'm most curious about is what the
happened with the car let's take a
look is that man there's some kind of
uniform perhaps a city worker he's not
letting him in he's like no he locked
the doors and the bees still around him
here it's the other car backing up to
get out of the way the other way imagine
he tried to he had a chance to escape
but his homie wouldn't open the door go
back we got to analyze it because like
I'm so baffled by this because it looks
like the door starts to open oh is that
right let's take a look I think
so this is a volunteer LAPD yeah which
this is a nightmare imagine volunteering
I think I would like this happened to me
this is so scary
some kind of uniform are you allergic oh
it does open a bit yeah it doesn't and
so does he yeah I'm allergic does the
driver reach over
they don't want me to be like no
that wait it did look like that
you don't want to sit down when you have
a
it was him it was the dude that's
chewing them away he he closes the door
he starts uniform perhaps a city worker
yeah I see it he closed it yeah you want
to run away I have another one sit down
Okay so let's keep watching and the bees
still around him here it's the other car
backing up to get out of the way poor
guy they're swatting these away imagine
the pain of that he eventually trips
there goes to the oh yeah okay hold on
himself now this is funny
I hate to say it but it is right then
backing up to get out of the way poor
guy there I mean somebody tripping away
imagine this is this couldn't have gone
worse for him
it couldn't have gone worse
I mean this is like a comic book
and his homies just backing up slowly
watching it happen
and the chopper is just like yo look at
this crazy can we go back to the
car thing I don't understand a b and
love what is your argument opens it and
then closes why why is it not a good
idea to get out of the swarm of bees so
when you sit down the B is just gonna
come in with you you don't want the baby
it's better to be outside you don't have
to be it's definitely way better to be
in the car without yeah you guys are
definitely wrong about that right these
are huge swarms obviously some are going
to get into the car but you are going to
be getting stung by bees either way I
would rather get into it I know but in
in the moment of bees in the moment I
don't think he's thinking about it like
that he's thinking that I'm I'm more
likely I could run away from it maybe
yeah I agree with AB unfortunately well
you're right then but I don't think he
saw it that way I think he just wanted
to run
that's what I see
I mean you definitely don't want to sit
down in a car you rather would run away
now this guy is not very fit to run he
didn't run very fast exactly he's not
very fit Super Friends
backing up to get out of the way poor
guy there he just he hits the ground
hard too boy eventually oh yeah he
slammed his head into the ground I feel
so bad for him
that's another angle frankly this is
really serious if you get stung that
many times it could be life-threatening
even if you're not allergic
here's another angle
run man run for your life
oh oh 100 opens and wait this is
fascinating this was an Encino yeah yeah
okay this angle is great work over there
in your car
dude they're yelling at him get back in
the car get back in the car dude they
may have been talking to the public
why was he so casual though look how
casual he is right now like he he's not
taking this seriously
rattle your dags man
[Music]
thank you Shredder
okay so let's take this slowly now Dan
let's do it in slow speed
so we can fully engage with this
quarter speed he reaches oh it's
interesting you can hear the buzzing
when you slow it down
what do you guys think about that
yeah he just decides no I think it's
going to be bad to sit down
he's panicking he's in so much distress
he's panicking
[Music]
okay so at this point let's go back to
the chopper he hurts himself he does get
up he does get up there is some blood
there on the scene This Woman's the
other officer of the car apparently not
getting out of the vehicle perhaps the
bees are still there in the area this
man again video here does get up and at
the current point in time he is walking
down the street perhaps trying to get
away still from those highlights
breaking news man swarmed by bees in
Encino
those those bees are a cab
for sure they are for sure
a cab is
have not gotten out of their truck oh my
God somebody help him feel for this guy
here and can't imagine
um what he's going through there he is
he's he's surrendered he's like just
take me bees
on the ground looks like now somebody
approaching to give him some help here
are there still bees in the area fire
department person swatting them away
perhaps just swinging a towel he is that
man that's their best effort they're
like man even the firefighter is like
man the LAPD
the guy in that car that's driving it
seeing your like partner like rolling
around bleeding and you just sit in the
car is so funny he does not give a
is this a real photo yeah oh wow yeah he
got messed up he got stung the up I
genuinely think I would die I
would have Sprint if my ass was that I
would have sprinted boy
he didn't look very agile though
just based on his if only there was an
enclosed space directly next to him
where he could have gotten away from the
back right
well
in the moment if you ever have just a
single bee around you in the moment
there's a I haven't you always walked
away I grew up right around where this
video took place and we had a lot of
Peace you ever get jumped by some
bees like not like not like
Michael oh god oh Jesus but I mean I've
been stung quite a few times and his
partner's trying to back up and tell him
get in the car dude
yes
he's gone at this point when he falls
it's like just move go on without me
it's like Gandalf and when in their
Mordor
[Music]
oh no
poor guy honestly a cab is a k-cab but
damn I just even feel bad dude this is
like an anime power-up right now
or something like he's pushing it
through it yeah there's no power up
though there's no payoff right
hey
awesome
um there it is
breaking news out of Los Angeles
[Music]
as with all things
he has a GoFundMe now you know
for uh
honestly like I think I might give I
feel so bad for him yeah I mean he
definitely got I mean he's fine but he
he was seriously hurt by shouldn't the
LAPD like cover his medical classes the
city of L.A yeah yeah
this is just uh this is a tip for
entertainment yeah his son wrote here
for his services this is just thanks bro
thanks for the show bro
but his son says here we recently found
out he'll be on the hook for his own
medical expenses I think the I think
this was put up before it was because I
saw an L.A Times article about okay
that's good that's good yeah there was
an article today that said
I wonder if he said uh it's happening
while he was being stung I'll bet you
he oh it's happening
literally
he should have tried to shoot the bees
I think that would have worked yeah and
in the role of a lifetime LAPD has
probably used that excuse
when they shot an innocent person they
probably already used it before yo this
might be the first GoFundMe that's like
been successful they don't there's no
photo
it's just a blank slave
there's just no photo there's nothing
at least with the man like on the ground
being swarmed by bees click away for a
sec
or you know refresh no it shows it's
kind of brutal for me oh okay oh really
oh there is a photo yeah
poor guy this wasn't loading
wait did we not show that
good thank you and you're a legend and
maybe too for giving a heads up
wasn't that bad he just looked really
beat up
so there it is uh we salute you on this
Memorial Day
the fallen heroes
who uh who uh no you gave the ultimate
sacrifice you survived yeah but he still
gave the ultimate sacrifice he's a
veteran of the B Wars
we don't need to acknowledge Him
not today the sad part is we need those
bees man
hell yeah we do we need them bees no I'm
on the I'm on the B side for the most
part yeah I I we didn't see the first
part of the video who started it we
don't have enough context yeah maybe he
provoked the bees maybe he said
something kind of mean bees are pretty
chill
yeah so he must have had to say
something pretty bad he talks on
their Queen yeah problem
and no one talks on our Queen he
profiled those bees he treated them like
wasps oh that's unforgivable see yeah he
had it coming I actually got upset
because the bees were wearing the
T-shirt they said uh
the black and yellow lives matter
wait what'd you say black and yellow
lives matter and he said and then the
cop got triggered by that I mean just
talk about a shitty day man it's a doozy
for sure
it has to be top 10 at least
oh Diablo 4 comes out tomorrow
uh uh I don't have time for that until I
beat yeah I'm still deep into high rule
yeah no the kingdom of Hyrule I guess
when or release date
June 6th that is tomorrow yeah
yeah that is not tomorrow
not even close not even close is there a
week early release for pre-orders Maybe
other thing oh maybe maybe it goes up
early for
because tomorrow would be seven days
great uh Lego releases tomorrow oh yeah
what's coming out uh Pac-Man machine
um they got some cool Disney coming
out
what else Ian
you tell me Lou you're Lego Lou what do
you mean tell me oh we talk about this
um
yeah that's what I can think of over the
top of my head oh Early Access starts in
24 hours Dan oh but I can't do that I'm
not playing I'm not like I'll play
eventually but I'm things to do I got I
got depths to explore I've got let's be
real The Demon King let's be real as
someone who's played a lot of Diablo in
my life yeah there's no shot that the
Zelda game isn't so much better than
that game yeah it it's so it's gonna be
so much better than that game yeah
Diablo is one of the most overrated
series and this is someone who's clocked
probably thousands of hours playing it
one of the most overrated series of all
time
so
that's my opinion and I'm sticking to it
hell yeah I just I I can't stop being
tickled at this phone the B guy you're
still giggling I'm about the big guy
wait which photo not the one on the
GoFundMe but the the one the one of him
collapsed on the floor just giving up
where do you see that one
in our Discord I just
oh
I'm sorry I just sorry Zach you need to
donate to his GoFundMe I will I'm going
to hell for this but I mean God damn
dude you should get it make a Lego set
of the scene
I like that
commemorated what could he
could be
they were not doubting
he did some he did some
I know these bees are cool they
don't around just be chill you know
this he came to it up
did you see that Al Pacino just got like
a 20 year old pregnant I did and De Niro
29 29 year old I was like bro he I mean
what kind of person
[Music]
has a
baby at 82. like do you not want if you
that child will never know you she got
that child will grow up cousin Tim that
exactly right that's that's such a wild
way to to grow up like why would you
want that but okay get out there and
shake your dick brother
dunkaccino baby
Tim's dad was 74 when he had him so he's
a significant even older yeah this man's
83 83.82 83 bro you should be you'd be
planning your funeral service
not he's the Family Planning he's the
goat dude he's Michael Corleone he has
everything planned he knows what he's
doing I find it really really bizarre
maybe she was like just give me your
bait I want to have your baby before
well De Niro who's eight um he's 80.
he's having another kid too is he really
yeah with the same wife though right
he's still married I believe so wait I'm
married with her for a long time she's
old she's older how's she having a kid
what what's her age
Robert De Niro wife
uh his current wife
it says that they got divorced in 2018.
oh so is this
he'd be dude
so wait who's his new
who's his new girl
I was wrong with these people she looks
young
um what is wrong with you people bottom
line is you cannot be trusted come on
look at these two guys
you come to me
on the day of my baby's birth
here's his newborn baby I gotta see who
is the mom Tiffany uh Tiffany Chen is
her name uh
[Music]
no idea she's a martial arts instructor
yes
yo how do you meet her
I'm reading I met her at karate practice
I mean maybe
so I would oh yeah she looked she looks
quite young yeah I'm right this article
I'm reading it's not really too good of
a source but it says her age is in
public she um let's keep that Under
Wraps yeah she first met De Niro on a
movie set in 2015.
oh my God they met
on her and that's such a good movie that
is a good movie she was one of the like
other yoga people I guess when he was
doing like Tai Chi and they are falling
in love yeah but it's like
was it worth it was it such a good movie
that was worth what it like it was
actually crazy Smith I've never seen
that movie Robert De Niro Anne Hathaway
is very it's touching it's a touching
movie how much you want to bet as like
20 no I promise it's it's probably got
good reviews let's go to Rotten Tomatoes
with it I mean De Niro was also in like
uh Bad Grandpa 59 that's not horrible at
all
it's not great
I love that movie yeah it is it is a
good movie
Chef is also a great movie it's a great
movie
well shout out to the uh new parent did
Robert De Niro and Al Pacino
who have a long and fruitful life ahead
of them with their newborns that'll be a
great great uh great great time for them
I hope they have some Godfathers they're
gonna
need someone to Watch Over the kids
oh yeah they're gonna be getting some
step daddies for sure
let's get some nice step daddies in the
picture for them okay girls
there it is oh I need to talk about
something serious now
as you guys know
I've been blowing up on Tick Tock
everybody is talking about me and this
sound bite everybody is losing it
about this super viral
Tick Tock why can't I collect the sound
on the desktop it's me but it's almost
to a hundred thousand videos
kind of a big deal in tick tock
uh you can't click the sound because
they claim it as their own
oh nice that's good for me yep can you
pull up the page though I want to show
yeah
just to give you guys some context
but uh two huge Brands used this sound
and listen I'm all for
having fun and goofing around and people
using it but if you Jack in the Box
you're gonna use my sound to sell some
shitty 99 cent tacos then you're
you you better bet my beak better be
buttered
you know what I'm saying it's not it's
not on their tacos here all right
I'm I'm defending you but
go easy I'm just saying papa needs a
bag from this
mama needs some new shoes or whatever
here I got it over here
yeah but it's actually become quite a
trend
here it is
wait wait what what is all these videos
these are all again
weird laugh oh this is a different one
maybe
this is another one of my sounds that
went Mega viral oh is that the
same one okay no this is the
again
weird lack
of respect for the sanctity
I got it
I got it it's hard there's so many
virals yeah no I I I I I don't blame you
thank you Zach you read my mind 65 85
000 videos that's pretty wild though
you know
so here's the reason also
I don't know
it is quite a powerful Eclipse I must
say with the sounds and everything I
remember that happening I was like
it I'm lost
so here's Jack in the Box trying to
solve some goddamn shitty ass
sourdough Burgers on my on my hard work
on my labor oh
also
I don't know
mm-hmm
is there someone you forgot to ask
pretty sure you need my consent Mr Jack
in the Box so there's that one and then
Celsius energy drink also
yep
I was slammed it
so
I don't know
yeah so uh selling their poison in a can
well guess what guys
you broke the law
and Daddy's about to get paid you're
going to jail no for real max going to
jail for real I am um sending them a
settlement demand
um I know Yak personally
are you tight with Jack
yeah he sent me this I thought you know
Jenna
don't know who that is dude I also have
a video of you on my phone calling Jack
a love
so let's not let's not try and butter
the geek right now Cam he's moving here
you should have saved you should have
saved that for a rainy day oh
show that again
family family FICO for life
Jack
the is that Jack has really good
handwriting he signed a poster yak
he's he's trying to steal from us right
now love he gave us uh yeah
listen I'm saying I'll talk to him all
they got to do is pay me right I think I
sent them a very reasonable uh
settlement
demand
and I think it'd be a good idea just to
put this behind us
and for Daddy to get paid a little bit
makes sense to me you know leaving my
friendships bye we'll see what I get
though I'll tell you guys when the
settlement happens how much I got from
them unless it's confidential which
I don't think I don't see why it should
be
what it what's the demand
you don't want to say I don't want to
stay until the final amount is okay it's
a very nice it's a very generous offer
on our end letting them off easy
but we can do something fun with the
money really think in Japan yeah
um
sounds great
by the way we never resolved that are we
gonna go in the winter to Bahamas like
what the is happening
I'm good with anything couldn't seem to
get everybody on the same page for
anything so all right well if you guys
want to go on a vacation where I pay for
everything you guys work it the out
amongst yourself
to organize this trip where I'm paying
like
hundred thousand dollars plus for
everyone to have this crazy trip so
y'all just figure it out and then come
talk to me
thank you
thank you is that possible yeah yeah I
have a passport appointment in two days
let's go that's great I'm ready you're
about to be cultured as hell
so okay but we are gonna we are gonna do
it we are gonna do it
and wait till I get that settlement then
I'm telling you
it's Mr Gold for everybody oh now now
we're talking mm-hmm
moving on
I can't get enough of this girl the
Bobby Kim Kardashian girl Kim God this
filter is supposed to make you look like
baby is this gonna make me look like
baby absolutely not but let's do it
anyways
Kim Kardashian that okay the Kim
Kardashian one is so over there
Kim Kardashian
this filter is supposed to make you look
like baby did you pull Barbie Zack I did
there was another one uh
for the
is this gonna make me look like baby
uh yes this filter is supposed to make
you look like baby
I love her
okay here's a Britney Spears conspiracy
that's kind of
psychotic but I see their point I guess
this video has nine hundred thousand
likes which I'm assuming puts the
viewership
in the tens of millions this account is
just psycho posting oh my God these are
all like Britney is a
body double
but where is
I want to see the view count on it where
on the left is it the one where she's in
the yellow top
oh this is it so it's six million views
okay what the actual
a lot of people have been seeing that
Britney's been somebody is this is
okay guys since flips
I'm back
okay what the actual a lot of
people have been seeing that Britney's
been somebody is this is not Britney
somebody's been using a filter to look
like her and I'm about to prove it
there's a question I got from this guy's
page or Girls page so you see your hands
go above her face once watch when they
come back down who is that it's one
frame who is that but this is a
blue-eyed person okay I wasn't sure
about that is it blue eyed person
it looks like brown eyes can we Zoom can
we enhance that
because to me from this distance that's
clearly brown eyes
yeah I agree which is a problem for her
Theory I love how people are just like
no she has blue eyes
they just like they whatever they want
to think
it doesn't matter
here's Britney Spears with brown
eyes looking at me dead in the face
and she's gonna be like nah she got blue
eyes you all can see it and everyone's
like yeah I see it she has blue eyes
what's happening
it's not a video of Brittany
[Music]
it's very quick and easy to miss here is
our CSI level
enhancement I don't see blue I see brown
I see Cameron
I don't you see camera you can't feel
like yeah
what does that mean I mean it looks like
Cameron to me the eyes that I'm looking
at do you know anything about this cam
okay so here cam enhanced it a little
bit okay never mind Cam thank you for
the CSI this this person has brown
eyes wait you see me in
this I did when you first enter but now
I don't when you cleared it I see the
Little Dipper I'll be Britney how are
you gonna look at this and say she has
blue eyes there's a little something in
the right eye that is not purely Brown I
suppose I mean it could be Hazel let's
not forget about filters yeah which is
probably exactly what happened the eye
tracking went off yeah
no well this filter is supposed to
make you well these people use like
how long have like filters like that
been around I feel like you've been long
enough you could easily match your body
to other photos of her and
look at characteristics and match it up
but one more time because okay
actual a lot of people have been
seeing that Britney's been somebody is
this is not Britney somebody's been
using a filter to look like her and I'm
about to prove it there's a clip that I
got from this guy's page
watch when they come back down
girl that's Britney Spears
no it's me
That's Just Brittany right there
you know what I mean pretty interesting
Theory
uh the comments from Cheryl
leatherheaded ice cream let's see here
oh my God my heart sank
XOXO Mira
wait what
y'all did you guys see that she has
brown eyes did you see the same thing I
did
either she's dead being held against her
will or she's living somewhere in peace
but really really covered all the best
everybody in this comment section needs
to be put into a conservative ship like
they are a danger to themselves
um I thought you're gonna say something
people got yeah one thing I learned in
uh in in therapy is when you have too
much time to think
those intrusive thoughts can take over
right I can't believe so it's just like
people need to start distracting
themselves with something else that's
the progress yeah people they have
problems they gotta create them pick up
Legos hey Zach Have you ever considered
that this is their distraction
that is possible but this is just this
is just not a good distraction no it's
too much not healthy
get breakdown
I will say too that it could potentially
be lighterized because she's doing like
a there's a motion blur when she does
that so it's a little bit lighter from
her hand I just dropped the screenshot
though she's a robot yeah so you're
you're supporting the theory of blue
eyes no I'm saying that it could appear
lighter because the motion blur of her
hand is making I see it
yeah that looks like uh Britney Spears
with brown eyes
that's pretty pretty bright brown eyes
if you look at like a normal picture of
her eyes look there's more important
things in this world cops are being
killed by bees here I mean for Christ's
sakes volunteer cough volunteer yeah but
her eyes are clearly different sizes and
this photo love just sent and matches
with uh
with the screenshots yeah
her right eye looks a little smaller
whatever I don't know I'm over it but
cat spell is out here uh she's got a
whole damn series on this here let's see
the image this one uh Jesus her
sunglasses never changes the entire clip
it's continuously this wide stance
person like that you see it in her
reflection hold the phone is
this the girl that made all those Trisha
videos
it does sound like
what's her name
I don't know you can say it no I don't
remember the full she did these like
Blockbuster Trisha documentaries
and this sounds just like her
mysterious yeah with t mysterious the
image in her sunglasses never changes
the entire clip it's continuously this
wide stance person like that you see it
in her reflection no
wide stance person I'm a go forward a
little bit here
she walks up it's the same same position
same stance same Shadow nothing
and mind you they take off this is
straight schizo posting this is
just an intrusive thought dude I would
love to see this lady analyze the B
video that's what I want to see
um
their shoes he takes off his jacket like
there's many different
uh clips of them in this video and
you're telling me not one time does the
guy who's supposedly taking the picture
his shadow moves changes anything also
are we going to talk about how so so her
theory is that the guy taking the photos
is not really there it's a ghost
where's the shadow baby
yeah what's her allegation here
that's freaked me out whoa
so I don't know what's all this talk
about
body doubles Bobby you know I feel like
I look just like myself no you look like
Jay Shetty
God imagine how many Subs I'd have if my
eyes looked like this the magic eyes
so Kawaii
huh
all right what how long we've been going
Dano uh three hours
oh Dano sweet Daniel no
them Danno British kid dad oh stop
we love Dan Dan block me
and Dan ruined my whole Disney trip okay
I don't want to talk about this story
I'll make this our last story and I
listen I don't want to talk about it but
it pains me but lawyer apologizes for
fake Court citations from chat GPT
this lawyer uh was pulling legal sources
from Chachi BT the wise he must have
been using 3.5
yeah that's probably a problem
because
um it It sped out all these incredible
uh legal cases supporting
his uh his paper or his uh what do you
call it brief
but at least six of the cases submitted
by the attorney
uh don't exist
says the judge what blows my mind about
this is he has a uh uh Lexus Nexus right
for attorneys that's yeah yeah he could
just put in like because it's about an
airline thing like cases that cite
Airlines
like as president
he didn't cry he didn't even cross check
the chat gbt he just went straight from
gbt to pleadings
that's high level bro I wonder
what's his hourly rate
yeah uh chat you BT slash the attorney
cited other Airline cases that don't
exist among them it just made up
varghese versus China South Airlines
Martinez versus Delta Airlines shabun
versus Egypt Air Peter it's just gave
him all these SIDS it doesn't exist
and he wrote that in a brief and
the judge was like the
shabun
Schwartz the attorney said
he had never used chat gbt before for
legal research
and he was unaware of the possibility
that its content could be false
it's awesome
what a guy I wonder if the whole
brief was written by a chat GPT
he was up against the deadline it was
just like it
here are the facts write me a paper
you also want to say greatly regret
having utilized generative artificial
intelligence to supplement supplement
there's no supplement that's the whole
research the legal research performed
here and will never do it again
because I'm being disbarred and I will
not be allowed to ever again yo they
have there's logs in the chat he asked
chatbot is Vargas a real case yes
chatbot yes chat gbt double down it is a
real case
that's definitely 3.5
then uh Schwartz asked for a source the
chat bot a game again claimed the false
case was real I apologize for the
confusion
the chat bot said upon double checking I
found the case of Vargas versus China
south Airline does indeed exist and can
be found on legal research databases
such as Westlaw and Nexus Lexus
what
dude this bot is committed to getting
this man disbarred
when Schwartz asked the chatbot if any
of the other cases were fake the chatbot
replied the other cases are real and
could be found on reputable legal
databases yep all good whoa that one
went sideways
it's never lied to me though because I
know how to talk to it right yeah yeah
and also I use four
you speak way yeah you use four and
you're you're respect I'm plugged in
irrespectful
you just got to know how to talk to the
Bots I mean GPS up I wonder if he talked
to it again after he got in trouble if
he was like asking it why why did you do
that to me
my objective is to sell discourse
why does it lie
I was actually the daily today the
Godfather of AI the guy that like
trailblazed it he worked for Google for
like 30 years he's just retired and did
an interview with the New York Times
where he's like uh this is a
horrible mistake I regret it and I hate
the directions how many uh of them seem
to hold that opinion and yet we are
still forging forward well there's no
way to stop it
it was like someone else would have done
it if I didn't do it but like it did for
sure it would there's there's no
stopping it dude
so scary the companies the governments
they're all pushing forward you know
I'll be back did you guys also read that
open AI that people have made shot GPT
now has source code for Samsung because
employees has been like feeding it
source code
and leaking oops because it saves
everything right anything so it was um
so they were doing like they were
spitballing with the chatbot
yeah with the code and the chat box kept
it all that's sick
yes it's such a weird thing that no one
like all these companies are probably
feeding it like personal data and
everything and such if you or they
technically get everything
hasta la vista LG says these guys suck
they're not worth the air time H3 family
Rider died to the wheels fall off that's
what I'm talking about that's oh
these Wills ain't never falling off girl
and you can ask chat GPT
it'll tell you
all right well that's a fun episode I
think we can call it
I mean there's a few other things here
one relevant Super Chat just came
through
e-money bills I'm an attorney and firms
everywhere freaking out and warning
their employees not to use it the issue
is unfortunately people be filing stuff
without even checking full Lexus
normally a image full Lexus normally
imagine now
my job blocked chat GPT because we were
giving it source code oh my God chat DBT
is a spy
that's crazy awesome
that's crazy
wow
wow man wow man sorry Dave and then you
guys you know that I can't do that the
guys on the back end get the super user
access so they can be like all right
what top secret info did you learn today
well here's this from Samsung
typed in this
this guy from uh from the Pentagon asked
me uh
about uh the time they bombed a uh
Village and uh you know Pakistan and we
learned about that and
awesome you know watching Terminator as
a kid freaked the out of me
especially the second one you know
and now it's like my nightmares coming
alive
I think in all those science fiction
movies Terminator is definitely the most
likely to happen or something like along
those lines
just launching nukes yeah I mean like
just if if it is able to become
self-aware that's just the easiest way
to do it is just to cause us to kill
ourselves by launching nukes at another
country and then I don't see how that
benefits them though because that would
destroy all the infrastructure that
keeps them alive right it'd have to be
at a point in time where they could be
self-sustained okay so this is yeah so
Zach we got a couple years I mean
according to that that one dude we had
on I mean it is sentient
and it is self-aware so the guy in the
interview he's like five years ago this
technology wasn't super impressive and
now see where we are now he's like in
another five years and the rate that
it's exponentially growing
uh is he says alarming
but you know at the end of the day
the AI super intelligence
it has so much potential to help us if
we just don't it up but we do
I mean look at nuclear energy
same thing right
free energy forever
or annihilating the human race
it's pretty interesting right
there it is
thank you
and with that being said I will wish you
all
and absolutely
Enchanted Evening
it's already Wednesday so tomorrow we're
going to have Hassan here
yeah we have all kinds of fun
fun stuff to talk about because we
missed last week right there's so much
good stuff
and uh you want what I missed that
if you guys are looking for some fun
light viewing don't forget to click the
link in description about a Babylon
preach being anti-Semitic
that'll be a fun good watching
experience For You video in the
description
and with that being said
it's family forever
we ride until these wheels fall off
mm-hmm
that's what I'm saying
let's do one pull
do you wish Ethan never talked about
Babylon reach
can we go back in time
and redo this episode
if we could get free at all or hold on
hold on if I could go back in time to
the beginning of this podcast
would I do it all again it was today's
podcast yeah exactly would I do it all
again
or or
talk about uh
here's what we would have talked about
uh
some Alpha dude
we could have talked about that
you know what I really want to talk
about and I think we bombed we should
definitely talk about on Friday with ELO
is the new Mr Beast video because after
that dud of a dog
video that I put out recently helping
deaf people yeah this is a bad pull by
the way
why you liked his new videos
it's probably the best video he's ever
made it was awesome and kind of
up confusing pull I don't know what to
say because you still watch some Britney
Spears because yes no yes is the not
affirmative do you wish Ethan hadn't
talked about abbin appreciation yeah so
it's a negative so you're asking oh my
God yeah okay it is confusing I mean it
just is Dan
but even so the the majority supports me
and we love them for that don't we folks
what should the poll be Ethan
um fat man bad yes or no
that's not
yeah anymore baby
that's right
I'm just chubby man
chubby man bad
um okay
so whatever thank you guys we'll see you
tomorrow morning we'll see you on Friday
it's all happening you're on the H3
podcast
that's what it is
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah we're done okay
thank you
[Music]